so mm-hmm msnbc told me that civil war
is starting so uh you guys don't get to
drink because i didn't say it they said
it don't look at me i'm just sitting
here you know i'm sitting here minding
my own business and then joe biden comes
out with red lights and the marines
yelling about how half the country is
all evil and everything and then msnbc
they said the civil war is now
literally tiffany cross said it feels
like civil war is here and previously
said civil war is here and so uh if
that's true msnbc and joe biden did come
out and say the things that he said that
is um
is that a declaration of war there's
tons of prominent democrat personalities
likening this to 1860 and 1940 saying
that this is a presidential wartime
speech
that's what they think
so i'll tell you this to those that
don't think you're in some kind of civil
war
that's the advantage they have the
element of surprise that when the feds
go after donald trump when they raid his
house when they start going after the
lawyers
they just tell you oh it's it's all
normal it's not a civil war and people
sit back and just watch but uh if msnbc
said it far be it for me to tell them
they're wrong they're msnbc
before we get started my friends we got
a great sponsor for you we got biotrusts
stronger bones and i'm sorry biotrust
ageless multi-collagen over at
strongerbones in life.com
got it you'll get 51 off when you pick
up your ageless multi-collagen this is a
great supplement makes your skin your
joints your hair and your nails extra
strong and i recommend it i skate all
the time and i've been feeling really
really good i love this stuff head over
to strongerbonesandlife.com you'll get a
51 percent uh you'll get 51 of today
you'll also get a 60 day money back
guarantee the healthy aging support of
collagen in its ideal forms five key
types of collagen you need from four
different sources and for every order
today they will donate a nutritious meal
to a hungry child in your honor through
their partnership with no kid hungry.org
to date biotrust has provided over 5
million meals to hungry kids please help
biotrust hit their goal of 6 million
meals this year it is non-gmo and free
of artificial colors flavors
preservatives and sweeteners free of
gluten antibiotics and rbgh and rbsd
nearly no odor or taste unlike bone
broth there's no clumping unlike other
supplements you'll get free shipping
with every order free vip live health
and fitness coaching from biotrust team
of expert nutrition and health coaches
for life with every order and their free
e-report the 14 foods for amazing skin
with every order
big fan of biotrust man we really do
appreciate you guys sponsoring the show
so check out strongerbonesandlife.com
if you'd like to pick that up and also
go to timcast.com become a member
support our work directly check out the
latest episode of cast castle featuring
marjorie taylor green it's a good it's a
good laugh we also have a clip up on
youtube the next week's episode is going
to be
funny and spicy
and i'll just say i'm pretty sure that
if it's going to be it's a four-part arc
now it's four episodes
that like youtube would just let's just
let's just say youtube wouldn't
appreciate the the jokes that we're
making
are uh yeah we'll leave it at that but
we'll have uh we'll have more on that
next week when it comes out tuesday at 7
p.m smash the like button subscribe to
this channel share the show with your
friends joining us to talk about all of
this news and more is matt kibby hey
it's good to be back and uh i am the
head of uh organization called free the
people i'm also the host of uh kybeon
liberty a podcast that's co-produced by
free the people in blaze tv and our
whole thing is to tell beautiful stories
about liberty
and to connect with people
at an emotional level
and not just do the typical libertarian
thing where we just
sort of bombard people with logic and
facts and all and um downward sloping
demand curves and all that stuff that
economists do
um because i i realized
quite a bit ago that i was the unusual
one and that most people process the
world through their emotions tim you
talk about this all the time that
culture is upstream of politics and so
we we want to turn people on my team is
basically a video production crew i have
actors and artists and
and people that want to tell beautiful
stories some of those stories
are uplifting and some of them are
devastatingly dark
right on thanks for joining me thanks
for joining man we also have hannah
claire bermullo hi i'm hannah brimlow
i'm a writer for timcast.com
yeah sure she was right she was right
hey matt i'm glad you're here man i'm
ian crossland obviously if you don't
know already it's right behind me don't
forget it i'm glad you're talking about
emotions man i was thinking last night
what do i do in the show i listen to
what people think and why they feel the
way they feel yeah it's so important
everyone's different you know and you
start to learn about humanity when you
get a piece of everybody
thanks for being here man thank you 100
we were talking last night about how
feelings don't care about facts which is
something that i came up with on my own
because i started to realize that this
is why i think conservatives lose and
definitely libertarians good for you for
making a difference me and my little
t-rex armor over here let's get this
party started so the uh first story
we're going to go to uh we're going to
check in with our good friends over at
the babylon beach oh my gosh and over at
the babylon b every single article okay
almost all the new ones are the image of
joe biden with the red lights and the
marines behind him yelling and we have
biden abolishes office of president and
names self supreme fuhrer
biden signs non-aggression pact with
poland but announces invasion of poland
bravo babylon b
so uh here's the story from newsweek
joe biden compared to adolf hitler by
trump loyalists not just trump loyalists
many people are comparing him to hitler
whether they like trump or not y'all are
just in a cult but newsweek you know
i'll give some respect to because they
have uh bhatia anger sargon who's uh
she's actually pretty good and uh tries
to keep things a bit bound so that
that's okay i'll give him that one but
take a look at this photo we got to show
this photo from the previous night we
did that watch party but this photo has
taken the internet by storm this
this is a creepy photo
everybody who is sane is questioning the
judgment of the white house team
for yeah joe rogan yeah of course joe
yeah but joe i mean joe recently said
vote republicans all the normal people
normal guys
even sam harris said the optics were bad
on this one
yes but sam harrison and he said but
something something about my hatred of
trump
sam harris has gone insane
i tweeted like you need an intervention
bro but we'll get into that i want to
say we'll talk about sam harris after
the trigonometry for fiasco i mean this
is a prominent p but this he is a
perfect example of what's happening now
so um if we point out here margery
taylor green look at this
she tweeted what we all saw tonight from
biden i guess when president butterbeans
is frail weak and dementia ridden the
hitler imagery was their attempt to make
him look tough while he declares war on
half of america as enemies of the state
oh or it's real
twitter blocked this video and it says
the following media includes potentially
sensitive content
i'm going to click it are you ready
click
oh
it's biden with a fake mustache and
swastikas behind him
so we had to bring in a libertarian to
ask us what's happening is is joe biden
declaring himself the supreme chancellor
is he asserting that for the uh security
and prosperity the american republic
will be reformed to the first american
empire
so i didn't think of hitler i thought of
daenerys targaryen in that in that last
i think it's the last episode where she
goes i guess she goes full nazi in that
but yeah like
um
the the imagery is super creepy and i
think that everyone should be a little
bit freaked out about it but obviously
this wasn't an accident they didn't like
forget to frame the shot and realize
that it was going to be this blood red
kind of imagery and so the question is
is he
desperately talking to his base because
he knows he's going to get trounced in
the midterms
and and the only thing he has left like
you know the economy sucks and people
are paying so much
for for gas and groceries and there's
there's so much collateral damage caused
by lockdowns is the only thing you have
has left is to get every single person
that's turned on by the the
authoritarian imagery to show up and
vote in the midterms
or
is
it
about um his brain's broken is is it
real like is it real is this is it real
um i don't i think it's real
well
they asked him today do you i think
peter ducey asked him do you
like do you really think that the trump
supporters are how did he phrase it do
you have this
a threat to or a threat do you really
think the trump supporters are a threat
he said i don't think any trump
supporters are a threat
well last night he was demented dude
come on like so i think he what he
really thinks is a threat is cultism and
he's pointing out trump's call because
he was just president but cult is a
mystery
if he's saying i don't think any trump
supporters are a threat but he's talking
about a cult and he thinks trump
supporters are in a cult that makes no
sense it's like he's saying the cultism
of trump is dangerous but the people
themselves are not threatened no no no i
think he's walking it back somebody
tweeted they said uh the overnights uh
must have been really really bad on this
one oh for sure that picture came out
like 10 minutes after that
i bet they were when that photo came out
let's let's grab that photo again when
this photo came out of biden
like geez it's crazy dude the red lights
with him going ah and just one person
had to be like instead of it being blue
red blue why don't we have it be
red blue like yeah he would have been a
totally different game it would be still
weird but like this this picture's never
going away i think they know it and they
know it one of the networks slowly
tweaked it and made it pink
cnn
they knew and there was blue just
outside on either side but they cropped
it someone was like this is a great idea
we're gonna write the speech and you
know what we're gonna be super patriotic
and we're gonna put red right behind him
and we're gonna do it at night so it's
black and red it was to scare people it
looks crazy the other part is this whole
speech he's just throwing out buzz words
i mean he says that uh
mega supporters are extremists or threat
he says that there are uh threats to
democracy he invokes charlottesville
like he is doing anything he can to be
like
supporting donald trump is supporting
the worst of the worst and i need you to
be on my side because otherwise you were
against the foundation of america this
is a crazy statement it's like classic
uh othering the other team right and
that this is this is what every
authoritarian done is done through
history you dehumanize the opposition
so that you can do what you need to do
um i don't think it's a mistake and the
question is does he mean like i don't i
don't know what joe biden means because
he's reading a script
um i don't think he knows but his team
wrote that
with with very much a purpose of of of
minimizing the humanity of half of
america right now that's that's what's
so creepy about it even has that line
where he says like uh not every
republican is like that it's just that
their party is dominated and it's like a
uh invite to be like adam kinzinger like
you either need to align with the
democratic party even if you keep the
name republican
uh it'll throw you out yeah i was
talking to a friend about um what we
learned of our true friends when the
cult started forming
and i was saying that
you we we've known people our whole
lives
and all of a sudden these people don't
want to be friends anymore or they're
not answering texts or they're walking
away i mean larry elder told the stories
like this
and what you realize then is these
people
will say or do anything
to appear cool or to be socially
accepted but in reality they're all just
terrified and they're just saying
whoever i fear the most i will pretend
to be like
so sure enough as soon as biden loses
and he will because this stuff never
wins it never does i mean there are
periods where autocrats gain power and
then they lose power in the end it never
lasts forever
all of these people who defend this lie
for it they'll come out and be like well
i was always against it
they'll be the first and then what you
what you need to realize is
right now we're kind of lucky
in that you can see who is actually a
thinking person you can see who is
actually your real friend because you
can ask them a simple question and see
if their brain can process it so there
are a lot of people i know
that i'm like huh
i wouldn't have known that they were a
duplicitous scumbag until now so i'd
like to thank the cult for exposing all
of these people
so so fauci came out recently and said i
was always against lockdowns the biden
administration announced a couple days
ago that they were the ones that got
children back into schools
clearly the policies of this
administration and and i would have even
broadened it the policies of lockdowns
and dehumanizing people and telling
people they can't speak telling people
they can't leave their house telling
people that they can't go to their job
and feed their families this is all
coming to to a head
and which which goes back to my theory
that the only thing that the democrats
have
is this other rising and demonizing and
and getting every single
hardcore democrat the 34 or whatever it
is
to show up in the midterms because
midterms are low term low turnout
elections um clearly the people that
that have been damaged are going to show
up
and they're not showing up for biden
they're showing up for something else
and and that's
that's the the catastrophic
future that they're facing they knew
this in 2020 and they feel the same way
now biden does not rally anyone what
gets people to vote is the hatred of
donald trump yep so they've been
planning this for some time we saw them
propping up maga republicans in that
they were trying to get mag republicans
to win yeah because they knew this was
this was the trajectory
now that the primaries are coming to an
end the goal demonize maga hit them all
at once
that's the plan the one thing that
bothers me is he was saying that he
thinks that anyone that questions a free
and fair election is a danger which i
kind of like okay well how could he say
about hillary clinton i mean that's not
that's yeah that's not that's well she
did actually question the 2016 she never
stopped but the big problem is when you
have
election tallies being calculated on a
proprietary voting machine in secret
that's i would not just
default consider that free and fair
because it's in secret it's being
tallied i can't i can't see if it's free
i can't see i need to see the code did
you see what carrie lake said no so she
was asked about this like isn't donald
trump you know with he's threatening
democracy or whatever and she was like
asking about elections
asking like like every democrat did
after you know the 2016 election she
said people have a right to uh to to
question the process and how is that
anti-american or a threat to this
country or whatever that's an insane
prospect what they want to do
with the classified documents thing they
want you to think there's an authority
above the president when it comes to
classified documents they want you to
think that trump needed permission from
someone the national archives by the way
right they they want you to think that
as commander-in-chief you do not have
the authority is the duly elected you
know president or whatever to do these
things and this is
every step of the way they're trying to
make you think that you actually don't
have the right to be involved in the
process when you come out and say hey
we're doing a free and fair election so
i want to see those numbers on a on a uh
you know open source machine or the
public should have access to the code
the source code we should be able to see
them tally yeah yeah of by and for the
people that's the united states they're
trying to erase all of that make you
think that there's someone else you have
to you have to bend the knee to
yeah did you know did anyone else not
know that the national archives were the
final arbiter of of what was legal for
the president
i think it's fascinating
our country's highest authority is the
acting our acting archivist of the
united
a path to states could there be a worse
form of hell than the librarians taking
full control seriously well i was
looking this up today because we were
kind of talking about it with family
because they were like well
my mother-in-law actually asked she was
like what did hillary clinton do when
the fbi came for her documents and i was
like that's a great question let's talk
about that smashed their phones with
hammers bleach bleach bit the server yep
and they're all and she was not a
president yeah she didn't have the
classification authority she destroyed
cl classified is it it wasn't was it
been proven that she destroyed
classified information or she just
destroyed information her staff
destroyed information
was it her command
so she commanded her staff to destroy
information we don't know if it was
classified or not because well here's
how it works
if there's uh let's let's say you know
we've got uh we got a truth bomb on the
table from daily wire and let's say it
was evidence or something if i came out
and said ian destroy the evidence will
you commit a crime if i said ian cleaned
the table
well i didn't do anything wrong i should
clean the table and then ian goes and
smashes the truth bomb with a hammer
nobody committed a crime
so they're like well no one really did
anything it was one guy was just
preparing a server and she was just
telling him to clean things up
yeah we get it
let's talk about where we go from here
with joe biden as crack pottery
msnbc's eugene robinson describes
biden's speech as urgent wartime address
as network keeps evoking civil war shut
up fox news network keeps evoking civil
war civil war is trending constantly
over the past couple several months
msnbc's tiffany cross has claimed it
feels like the civil war is here in fact
she said more than that they have a
video clip here let me see if i believe
this is the one maybe it will play maybe
all right let's uh every time well
because we were listening to music we
have listen parties before every show
there is no let's deal with the rhetoric
at this point i do think we have to have
serious conversations around preparing
for actual violence uh people keep
saying a civil war is coming i would say
a civil war is here and i don't mean to
be hyperbolic we can look at what has
happened just in the past week alone
since all this has happened we've had
two people try to declare war with fbi
field offices i don't think at this
point we're going to all pack up our
bags and go home and sing kumbaya she's
right yup she's 100 right doesn't matter
what side you're on or who you think is
factually correct or morally correct
what matters is that there were people
going to fbi field offices one guy tried
to break through and i said yeah people
are getting violent you know these
things are happening and even it was uh
eric weinstein what is this auto play
video boo
eric weinstein
said uh he doesn't see a path uh out of
this and and i'm like you know with like
that that's that's that's great i've
been saying that for a while and i don't
mean that it's like a dick at him i'm
like even he's now saying you know even
joe rogan is saying i think tim was
right a civil war is coming even eric is
saying i don't see a path out of this i
said that a year ago i mean violent
crime has been on the rise for the last
two years i think i have to look at the
numbers again but i think it coincided
before the pandemic was exacerbated by
the pandemic we obviously saw the summer
of 2020 which was marked by violent
riots
you know it's hard to say whether the
civil war is coming or we've been slowly
drifting into it for some time i think
people expect there to be like a referee
whistle and for it to be like and we've
begun and that's never in history ever
been the case even even fort sumter
they didn't know if that was the start
of a civil war or not they were shooting
at each other like well you know this
could be nothing we don't know and uh
people can't see the forest for the
trees yeah i'm looking at this quote
from joe biden last night we can't allow
violence to be normalized in this
country but violence has been
increasingly normalized in this country
for so long i mean by him yeah and how
many times do we have to see like random
person stabs elderly women on the
streets of new york before we see that
violence is happening on so many levels
of our society in a way that we're not
used to can we get a joe biden clip
where he's standing in front of the red
you know shaking his fists and then we
just have like one of these lefties
going are we the baddies yes you are
it's you cheering on law enforcement and
governmental expansion and and violence
against regular people you know i want
to give a shout out to uh these left
commentators the social commentators who
are cheering on joe biden right now who
cheer on antifa because when antifa went
and smashed the windows of the working
class throughout a bunch of cities in
this country they cheered for that that
makes you the bad guys like you know if
you want to talk about evoking history
or or invoking history then um
crystal knocked sure
you were the guys who went around
smashing up everyone's windows and guess
what you did it in black neighborhoods
there's viral videos of people in black
neighborhoods begging antifa to stop
destroying their homes but whatever you
didn't care did you so you know what
when these people tweet like ben shapiro
tweeted you know biden's gone crazy and
i see hassan and vosh and they're like
seethe and laughing about it it's like
yes you guys they're they're evil they
they don't care that antifa went
destroyed the lives of working-class
people they're in favor of the elites
and the system i mean hassan bought
himself a multi-million dollar house
while claiming to be a socialist bravo
good sir that's the grift that's the
racket
you've done it very well
so when uh when the lockdown started i
want to give some context to this when
the lockdown started the first thing
that my wife and i did was go to home
depot and buy plywood to board up the
front windows on our capitol hill home
because i had no idea what was going to
happen but but my theory was that if you
lock people up
and you tell them that they can't go to
work and you tell them
dictating every aspect of their life
things are going to get violent and
that's that's precisely what happened
maybe maybe it was orchestrated but i
but i think another theory about what
biden is trying to accomplish and i
think this msnbc clip proves that
is that they want someone to take the
bait
they want to be able to point to some
maga guy that goes too far and gets
violent so that their narrative
completes right yes see i told you they
were going to get violent um so one way
to think about one one way to another
way to think about that speech is let's
goad them into doing something stupid
yes and then that's our narrative for
the election yes i like that theory
because it seems like social chaos is
brewing as a result of the lockdowns
since september 11 2001 people have been
out of their mind pointing the finger at
who's in who's at fault but like uh
uh it seems like an emergent phenomenon
that it is a violence of desperation and
that yeah
to acknowledge that would be like well
we've been riding off the back of the
federal reserve for 120 years this is
what happens when you defer your your
monetary responsibility and let people
print your economy into oblivion yeah
well just think about all these things
what they've done to children and and
all of the developmental damage by not
being able to go to school or masking
all of the people that died because they
weren't allowed to go to the hospital
and maybe they died of cardiovascular
disease maybe they died of cancer maybe
they couldn't say goodbye to their
parents who were dying
um the list goes on and on these these
inhuman indignities that that have been
imposed and fair or not and i think it's
fair the the biden administration the
democrats msnbc the lockdowners own this
problem so they have to come up with
something else because they're not going
to win
on the health of the economy they're not
going to win on even though they say so
they're not going to win because they
open the schools because that's a lie
so what are they going to do they're
desperate and they're trying to stoke
civil war
it's disgusting
i i think
civil war has been here for a while and
i think what we're seeing of them has
been an increasing desperation because
they've been losing
over the past several years there's been
a i mean since trump won no before that
i think it was even since obama was
president because it's a global civil
catastrophe we're in like a global civil
uprising where a new government's
attempting to form a one new world order
they're calling it and obama signing the
trans-pacific partnership like getting
on board with selling out to the
malaysian oil companies was part of it
it's like creating this corporatocracy
but trump was very against that and so
was bernie sanders which is kind of why
i think why he got snowballed by the
clinton campaign they were not really
into like yo let's sell out the people
to the corporations and acquiesce to the
metaverse you know uh
mute mutation um and but that was like
slowing it down i don't know if biden's
like in on it or if he just is being
pushed along with it bidenism he's i
mean he's he's part of the the regime
he's a part of the machine um someone's
writing his talking points for him i i
want to white pill you guys just for a
second here
um think about think about the
trajectory you mentioned the tea party
but you could go back to ron paul you
could probably even go back to howard
dean
and you could certainly fast forward and
look at bernie
and trump as outsiders breaking
the two-party duopoly
and and doing something that that the
establishment didn't want
and
every
step along the way
they've tried to whack it down it's like
whack-a-mole oh people are finally
speaking for themselves it turns out
that not every democrat wants hillary
clinton it turns out that not every
republican wants mitt romney
and there's this uprising going on
fueled by technology this is the upside
of technology it is democratization at
its best
and it turns out that people have a
voice and they have power and they have
control
and and this is this uh existential
fight that we have between the machine
that wants to crush us
and people that want to be free and i i
think we're in the middle of something
it maybe it's a civil war maybe we're
figuring out how different other
americans are across the country in a
way that we couldn't have possibly known
before
technology but maybe we're also trying
to figure out how to beat the man
and reorganize things in a more
decentralized way i think one of the
things we're seeing
you know i mentioned those people that
would just say or do anything to fit in
or be cool
they've
they've become stuck where they are and
so
they're all it's a mexican standoff
they're all looking at each other saying
what should i say what should i do and
there's no real leader anymore it used
to be that with a centralized media
apparatus you could say
blue is the new green and then all the
people go
yes blue blue
now that leader is gone now it's all of
just them and one guy goes green green
no wait
blue i don't know canceled they're
attacking each other and so they're
stuck and there's no way to lead them
out of it an example is
you know i've been watching she-hulk
have you guys watched that great piece
of american um media i love the first
episode i saw some twerking i liked the
first episode i liked the first episode
the second episode was okay the third
episode was just one of the worst pieces
of
film trash i've ever watched because
she's a good actor too it's really bad
it's it's just like the it's they're
making they're ruining characters but
anyway i digress it's it's getting bad
reviews it's got like a 2.2 or something
like that in in out of five
and so what these cultists do is they
say the only reason that's happening is
because white supremacists are attacking
it and then i'm just like it's really
funny because i actually liked the first
one i thought it was silly when she did
that rant about feminism but i was like
i even said in the show i was like oh
it's all right you know c plus it's like
kind of funny second episode it's okay
you know there's some bad stuff in it
and third episode is just really really
awful and it's like what do you say to
someone who actually praised the first
two episodes the first two weeks and is
now saying okay it's getting bad is that
racism and white supremacy the issue is
when there's no leader they don't know
what to say so they say bad thing they
say
the only reason people don't like it is
because they like bad thing
they they like bad things so they don't
like show and and you're just like maybe
if you had
charismatic thought leaders they could
explain what's wrong with the show in a
way that would help your side but they
don't it's a mob
and you know some people call them the
real fascists or whatever and i'm like
it's just a mob it's a group of people
marching around with pitchforks
figuratively on twitter looking for the
next person to be angry at over their
problems joe biden is a part of that mob
he is not a leader he doesn't know what
he's doing somebody writes them a speech
because they're a part of the mob and
they're saying mindless nonsensical
garbage but mobs are dangerous yeah it i
mean they're also just uh there's an
apparatchik mind mindset
to to people like this because the you
know the prize the ring
is is control of the federal government
and without that they can't impose their
will on other people
um whereas i think um conservatives and
certainly libertarians don't really
think that way we're not
we're not ultimately political animals
we want to live our lives we want to
raise our families we want to
live our lives the way we see fit
and and i think that's sometimes a
disadvantage when so much power is
concentrated in washington dc
um apparatchiks win
and people that that want freedom don't
even understand what they're doing
um so that you know the language is
foreign like what are you guys even
saying it's it's hard to even understand
what they're trying to say i think
they're trying to get you to agree with
them by using the only thing they know
which is fear so they're saying like
well only white supremacists criticize
she-hulk so therefore if you are going
to criticize it know that you are
equating yourself to that ideology and
so in turn if you don't want to be
outside the group you start to be like
well i kind of like the costumes and she
hulk and even though you didn't actually
like it you feel like you can't publicly
talk about it otherwise you were equated
to dude
it's like the show's bad because the
writing is bad the jokes don't make
sense the characters are being ruined
like wong he's in a bunch of movies he's
a great character and they made it they
made turned him into a joke like he's
disheveled he shows up late he's
committing crimes i'm like what is what
is this what are they doing these
characters but the cgi
so bad you know it's yes like
but bad is an understatement it's worse
than shrek people are like shrek level
cg i'm like no man the way they're like
walking and jerky and their mouths are
moving like this when they talk i'm like
it reminds me of sims you know yeah like
it looks like early early animation of
sims like in the worst way possible and
this is like a multi-million dollar
production right every you know what i
think i think when you're a when you're
a part of a mob
they're they they they may be able to a
mob can break into cnn but they can't
make the cameras operate the cameras may
already be turned on when the mob breaks
into the cnn you know headquarters so
they can move the camera around and
point it and that that that goes out to
the world but eventually the camera
stops working and they start scratching
their heads then someone comes in and
they're like uh let's do this and they
press power the camera starts working
but not working well and they're like
okay i got it that's what it feels like
like a mob broke into to to the uh you
know the studio and they don't know how
to work anything
and that's and you know i think merit is
being shut out but uh we're doing our
own things you don't you know it's the
danger of corporatocracy is that merit
gets shut out and wealth dictates who
gets to make the decisions instead of
the the most intelligent or the most
resourceful which is what republicanism
is so great for that the merits of the
human are what lead the way not that not
the bank account
well i mean is is it is it wealth or is
it is it woke-ism where where
who you hire is not based on the people
that could actually make a good movie
right i think i think that's what you're
describing oh man remember when like
star wars was completely destroyed and
then it was completely destroyed and
then it was completely destroyed and
like every step of the way they just
completely ruined the ip
like the prequels it's like okay you
know whatever
they they they really ham fisted it it's
like why is c3p0 and r2r2d2 here that's
anakin built see that's weird but fine
whatever we all had a good laugh we
enjoyed it then they started making a
whole bunch of weird garbage and then
the the sequel movies were just
nonsensical garbage
ryan johnson who super woke just totally
ruined it and he brags about how proud
he is but he legitimately ruined it the
rate like it's dude george lucas sold
out he sold star wars to disney he sold
out that was his ip
the freakish well good for him
he ruined it he gave up and he ruined it
first of all forcing his own direction
on it ruined it george you ruined the
first episode one you ruined because you
didn't let someone else take the reigns
for you you're a good story writer
you're not a good director my man that
movie was terrible
jar jar binks was a
child laughing to play the lead you had
no villain you had darth maul who didn't
even have lines in there like one line
in the movie
terrible terrible i thought you were
talking about a new hope i was like what
the new hope was good episode four five
and six were freaking incredible man
yeah they're an amazing cast confusing
how they did these these yeah i've never
understood it i've never really followed
star wars i feel like you're making a
really hot take i just wish i could
understand he wanted me to pretend like
i didn't know palpatine was the emperor
so that i could like
the kids in the future will watch star
wars from episode one
this is crazy
yeah i mean the moment
this calculation same actor everybody
knew it was him yeah it was the point
was it was the do you like star wars i i
checked out with jar jar binks and
i've had to go back and re-watch them
all recently but but i'm i'm probably
surely the oldest person here and i was
a
very young maybe i was like 12 when the
first one came out and that that was
like iconic definitive this was part of
our youth back then yeah
and um you know the first three which i
don't know which numbers they are
are four five and six four five and six
they just call them one two and three
whatever yeah prequels in the sequels
and then jar jar binks i'm like i'm out
yeah yeah how racist was that all this
like cgi cartoons i would rather had a
dude in a in a costume like that's what
they did in the original star wars dudes
with costumes on playing music and
that's shot first
oh and then they re-edited the star wars
to make han not seem so villainous like
khan's a dirty dude of course he shot
first he shocked so they didn't get shot
this is an example actually you know i
remember when they changed star wars so
that greedo fired at han first and it
was a big deal i'm like this is like
it's like proto-wokism when they started
chain like when they started making
content to fit their ideological
narrative going back and editing it
because they were like han shouldn't be
a scoundrel he should be a hero well and
they're hijacking they're hijacking
stuff that is necessary you said this
you were 12 when this came out it's a
huge part of your childhood they're
hijacking things that they know people
will want to watch to put their own
messages in didn't wasn't there like a
netflix show they went back and edited
the first episode was it stranger things
i think there's a bunch of them done
that's crazy because you know i remember
when uh when video games used to be
released the video game that came out
was the video game you got and when
there were bugs well you know too bad
and sometimes they go it's not a bug
it's a feature like the idea of in video
games a combo in a fighting game right
in street fighter it was actually a bug
that you could string together a bunch
of moves creating a no time gap between
when you attack and your opponent's
ability to defend and they were like
it's a feature they couldn't do anything
about it nowadays when when a game is
released they patch it
now they're patching tv shows
this is nightmare like time is gone
like
history memory won't matter because
you're going to go to your friend and be
like hey to just watch that new show
called you know about ian you know ian
and matt's adventure into you know the
never-ending detail or whatever and
you're gonna go like oh yeah it was
really awesome when ian pulled out the
lightsaber
lightsaber what are you talking about no
he had a ska excalibur
what no he draws a lightsaber dude i
just watched it bro i watched it when it
came out that's what they're doing
they're working on augmented reality
where depending on who you are you're
gonna see a different image on the
screen so like for kids when they watch
it they'll see coca-cola but when an
adult watches it they'll see beer a bud
light i'm just watching a video on this
it's crazy or when the adults watching
it they'll see you know a big apple
being like make sure you eat healthy
kids and then the kids are gonna be
watching it it's gonna be a giant tiger
throwing gummy snacks and i'm being like
eat candy it's delicious or something
the parents are going to think the kids
are getting a good message not realizing
it that's disturbing because part of
what bound us together you might have
mentioned this earlier is is our shared
may i don't know if you said this
exactly but our shared appreciation for
a shared understanding of what art was
like i don't know if you actually said
the surveys you tim but like we would
all sit around it was fox news gave us
the this is what's up tonight and
everyone would see it everyone could
agree that's what i saw for better or
worse because we were led astray in many
ways and but now we're gonna even be
like that's what i saw well that's what
i saw did we even see the same show i
don't know and i don't know how to
verify it
yeah how crazy is going to be
if you know
we we no longer have tvs we just have
like viewing portals that are green
screens and you put on your ar goggles
and then you're watching the news and
you get different news at the same time
like
i mean we saw this with the sandlin
testimony the gordon uh silent testimony
um there was a gym i think it's a gym
someone posted this photo
cbs and fox next to each other and on
fox it says sandlin confirms no quid pro
quo and cbs's sandlin confirms yes quid
pro quo it's like you literally have two
different
truths that are coming out and it's like
another good example has just happened
taiwan shot down a chinese drone it's
reported by you know a bunch of outlets
that it was a chinese drone why because
it came from china but then you get cnn
saying unidentified drone and reuters
saying suspected chinese drone and now
what happens is someone might go did you
hear that they shut down a chinese drone
they'll go no it wasn't identified what
are you talking about the news said it
was literally
this is insane i don't know how we
function this way well
i'm gonna wait pill you guys again
because i i really feel like um back in
the day like i'm the old guy again i'm
gonna be old guy all night but um i'm
old enough to remember when walter
cronkite would tell me as a kid that's
the way it is and you got 20 minutes of
spoon fed news and somebody curated that
and all three networks said the same
thing
and that was our only access to
information and now you have these
infinite sources
and all sorts of contradictions these
these contradictions of fact
prove to us
that that a lot of what we used to think
of as objective news is that best
opinion and perhaps just
blatant false propaganda
but we have we have the ability now to
to sort of fact check the fact checkers
and i think that that put maybe puts
more responsibility on us to figure
things out for ourselves and yes all
sorts of people are going to fall for
the bs but um i i feel more comfortable
in this crazy decentralized world than i
ever did when someone was dictating to
me what to think um
it's all broken man i feel less what
we're seeing but more hope what we're
seeing now with uh with the media and
the lies plays perfectly into the
post-modernist
goals sure the fact that you have fox
and cbs saying the exact opposite things
it is it is perfect for them
that we who will try and fact check and
then present to you the best to the best
of our abilities the facts
they like that we come out and say
they're lying to you and at the same
time they point back and say they're
lying to you
because it confuses people
but good for numbers and yet
that's sort of how life works right you
think about you think about your
everyday life and you're trying to
figure out how to move forward in a
radically uncertain world it's a world
we live in we live in real time and we
don't know what's going to happen
tomorrow we have some sort of theory
about what happened yesterday and
somehow we figure that stuff out so i
think i think it's important not just to
take the snapshot of like that guy says
this and this guy says the opposite and
i don't know what to think um there's a
process by which we're going to figure
this stuff out
and but again like we have to like own
that instead of just falling into the
trap of believing
one tribe and not the other i'll pull
this story from the new york post
white house big tech colluded to sensor
misinformation lawsuit good yeah new
york post you can just show the emails
that came out showing that they
literally did it this is this is crazy
who's following the lawsuit uh a bunch
of people i think it's gateway pundits
involved the state of missouri is
involved i think that's the that's the
lawsuit that where this is coming from
this uh i just had uh jen and eunice on
my show and it hasn't even come out yet
but she i'm i'm gonna look up her her
association because she is a
co-plaintiff with two attorneys generals
on this
and this discovery
is more like we knew this was happening
because the white house was actually
saying it from the podium and biden was
saying facebook is literally killing
people so this is not actually news
except they now have documentation that
there was a ongoing coordination process
where the government was dictating to
tech companies what they were allowed to
say and what they were a lot they were
demanded to take off and it's now time
to sue facebook into oblivion
anyone so you need to look at the emails
look at the stories
anytime joe biden has referenced
covid policies
i think anybody who tried sharing
anything related to that should should
join a class-action lawsuit against
facebook and the us government for
collusion violation of first amendment
rights because the government was
actively suppressing that information
with the assistance of facebook and you
are now you should now all have standing
large class action
that would be fantastic i'd be involved
in that i remember posting in 2020 about
some coveted stuff about some documents
and after that totally blackballed like
blacklisted yeah
no no notice that it happened i just
started getting three likes per per post
after that and now my i'm sure my page
is in some kind of blog i mean youtube
took down like what half a million
probably more than that videos that had
just code stuff and then changed their
policy and didn't put the videos back up
like there is an obvious censorship
element to this that they are not
willing to answer for okay so here's i
just want to fill in the blank there the
jen and eunice who's with the new civil
civil liberties alliance
and they um are representing uh uh jay
bhattacharya the the one of the signers
of the great barrington declaration
martin koldorf a couple other guys and
they have joined the louisiana missouri
attorneys general on this
and i i think it goes to the supreme
court louisiana yeah
oh wow i thought it was missouri is it
two missouri and louisiana wow
yep and uh this is gonna be big i think
it's a big deal um and and you know god
help us we need to save the first
amendment i still think that matters i
agree is that crazy am i i don't know no
we need to evolve the first amendment
because we're creating a global
government right now and i think free
software code is the future free speech
if you can see what the code is doing
then that's like your sense of personal
freedom in the environment if you go to
the metaverse and you can't see what the
code is doing around you it could be
telling you lies and you wouldn't know
it well so can a human
it's okay for humans to lie but for a
software code for an environment to lie
to you i think is when it's gone too far
what does that mean like if
there's
blatant lie propaganda like if there's
signs around you that are telling you
something happened when it didn't yeah
that's the metaverse i'm talking about
when you're in vr when you're in but
like that's an image posted by a person
what's the difference is i guess what
between what and what an image posted by
a person and a person saying the words
if someone creates an environment that
they post false advertising or they post
you know
false statement and political ads it's
created by a person even if it is a sign
that's physically appearing yeah
if i saw a sign that said like turn
right to the next burger king but to you
the sign said turn left to the next
burger king and but neither of us know
that we're getting fed different
information that's like a violation of
my first amendment that's a violation of
my of a human right in my opinion people
need to know if they're being led
towards you but you said it's okay if
people you will fly like why technically
you could lie to me if you have an
algorithm that's decided you should go
to wendy's and you should go to burger
king and it's automatically doing it
yeah we should know that machines are
doing that to us
when people don't realize you know
facebook experimented on people you guys
know this yeah they they they made
people depressed on purpose to see what
would happen that's
psychotic
we should have we should have a right
guarantee that they can't do that there
should be i mean i think we should
abolish algorithmic feeds
it should be chronological and your
followers so if you follow something you
hit shown it it shouldn't be like we've
decided what's right for you
because facebook actually started
showing people content that would
depress them to see if it would work and
it did they started then producing
depressing content it's creepy stuff
it's like 2014 i think they were doing
that
what are they doing now
oh yeah exactly mark zuckerberg is a
he's a psycho he's i think he's in a big
time into psychology that's a big part
of what this is for him as a psychology
experiment i mean he said that pretty
openly that he loves experimenting on
the human psychology i don't want to put
words in your mouth mark but you've
alluded to that fact i think he was in
college for psychology at the time that
he was building facebook um
yeah i agree man i you know we got a
it's a new world and we got to take it
by the horns if we don't it's going to
gore us
do you guys um think that technology
this kind of social media technology
that is doing all this stuff is this
generally been a good thing or is this
what's creating all of this chaos it's
the chaos it's neutral but people are
using it to create massive chaos i i
think the guys of american law like
proper
ip law i can't just own a world you know
technology is neutral but it's basically
like
you know
crystal meth
if you if you just start mass producing
it and giving it out to people
and it's like imagine if companies came
around came out they started giving up
free crystal meth to everybody in order
to have a job you had to have it it's
like you're going to come and work but
you're on meth right and you know that
would be insane we can see the problem
with that drug addiction but what social
media is is exactly that so when you
have a group of people that
don't really have the cognitive
faculties to lead
and i'm not trying to be disrespectful
to everybody but some people are really
dumb and some people you you can be
disrespectful too if they if they know
they're manipulating but you have people
who are just
blindly marching in lockstep with with
this uh gutter garbage algorithmically
fed nonsense you have to have it
they're creating a world of chaos and
nonsense
and that's what the modern left is i
don't view it as a political movement
sort of you know i've talked about this
it's a it's it's a chaotic destructive
force
it's like a fire that's all it is it's
like fire
you have the left and the right the
traditional left and right in this
country and that's why as i mentioned
the other day if i sit down with ben
shapiro we're going to disagree on your
traditional left and right disagreements
and then we're going to shake hands and
be like ah america is great but then you
have this left this quote unquote left
which is just a fire that burns there's
no reasoning with it
you could go up to it and you can say
here's a video of joe biden admitting to
a quid pro quo and they'll smack it out
of your hand and be like fascist fascist
fascist and just start screaming because
it's fire there's no rhyme or reason
a leaderless mob blindly marching in
lockstep on social media and that's what
you end up with but this is nothing new
and the entirety of human history has uh
um crazy mobs
doing the most
inhumane things uh mass murder stuff but
it's but it's amplified it's and it's
addictive like we we've always had crazy
people but we haven't always had systems
that incentivize you to post
inflammatory things
instagram right young girls are getting
depressed because they're not getting
enough instagram likes now they're doing
photoshops and filters on their on their
apps now women are getting plastic
surgery to look like the filters like
this is derangement there's a family
that's suing instagram because their
daughter started using it uh at a young
age like 13 or something and developed
really serious anorexia and anxiety and
and they believe that it's directly
correlated to her addiction to social
media well these ceos don't give their
kids phones
everybody else does and it's like the
dude selling the drugs knows not to let
their kids have it but the families are
told to do it's the right thing
yeah it's like an addictive printing
press fire drug we can we can go back to
web 2.0 get rid of all these weird
algorithmic manipulations just go back
to reverse chronological that'd be
fantastic if you follow them you follow
them otherwise the posts just come in in
reverse chronological order i hear the
web is headed towards 3.0 and it's
freaking out humanists well we're in 3.0
3.0 is like the perma web where
everything is on our weave or some other
permanent state where it's always there
and that's what we're talking about 4.0
geez i don't even know what to call it
web 1.0 was like compuserve and aol chat
rooms really basic stuff
garbage websites web 2.0 was when we got
social media websites accounts were
popping up ebay and things like that you
could then do transactions online
through websites and then web 3.0 was
the app network now now you're online
through an app that you can't navigate
away from except the app itself and then
the app can shut you off things like
that that's why there are web 3d so when
it first started you had crazy websites
and ips and you'd see like you know a
gif of macho man doing the peanut butter
jelly dance or whatever and hamster
dance and things like that then we got
web 2.0 which was like youtube and
myspace but they're still desktop
websites now you have web 3.0 where you
don't actually type in anymore you have
just apps and you press it and you're
logged in automatically and you interact
with them and they're heavily regulated
the internet used to be fun it's the
wild west
web 3.0 is awful
it's it's robotic it's it's it's mundane
yeah and then web 4.0 is i don't know
what they're
like expecting that to be like i don't
know it's it's the matrix that's we're
going to go straight
yeah nora link um okay
what about what about blockchain as the
alternative to this and and there's some
experiments well what is what does that
mean
it means that we could go back to the
fun internet and we could go back to the
unregulated and you just make it yeah
this is like just there's no appetite
for it people aren't doing it nothing
there's something stopping you from
making
you know bringing back an aol server
with messenger and chat rooms
people don't do it well if we look at
what the fbi has been doing there are
things that can try and stop that from
happening unfortunately like they
stopped facebook from letting things
happen on their website so before there
wasn't a lot of government overreach
that we knew about in late 90s 96 97
when people were typing on aol chat
rooms logs weren't being stored i don't
know if they still have those aol chat
logs from 30 20 years ago if they want
them but the the technocratic state's
been in high alert for the last 20 years
and really building up a way to spy you
know the prism network where they're
allowed i think legally even now
yeah it's not right we publish all of
our stuff on odyssey um in the
anticipation of youtube finally deciding
that that our stuff isn't allowed
anymore and we're not we're not going to
be first we're not alex jones we we tell
beautiful stories and
and i don't expect to be the first to
get banned from anything but what they
want to do is they want to turn the
internet back into tv
they want to
yeah that's exactly what they want to do
what the big tech guys and the
government have been trying to do is
when there was web 1.0 subcultures
started flourishing with web 2.0 they
started solidifying and building
economics around themselves then they
realized hey wait a minute these people
actually got trump elected they were
memeing him into into power by making
jokes and people were sharing them it
was me magic and they said we have to
stop that
so now the goal is
approved narratives only on all of these
big platforms and that's it they started
banning conspiracies and all the fun
content man it was it was a it was a
good day you know back in what like 2010
i'm super curious when you could watch
flat earth videos and they'd be on the
front page of youtube and you'd be like
oh that's so dumb and silly and now it's
like you go to the front page and you
got mr beast and you got cnn but this
this is the whack-a-mole that i'm
talking about is like every time people
get new tools to be more liberated and
think for themselves they come in with a
new scheme more aggressive more
authoritarian every time they do it to
try to shut it down
and then something else emerges and i i
think that there is a technological
solution because
um i don't want to live in the matrix
and i don't think most people do what
concerns me about the whack-a-mole thing
because you're right when people are
whacked down they tend the consciousness
will rise up somewhere else and it'll
keep happening and they keep trying to
stop it but if you don't know you're
being whacked if you think everything's
going out normal but it's being tweaked
somewhere between you and the listener
because of out secret algorithms then
there might not be an uprising because
you don't even know you're being
manipulated that's what i'm concerned
with and i want to avoid well you can
see trends like um young people make fun
of people that are on facebook now
that's what grandpa does
and they've migrated and they're they're
curating their own content they're
watching shows like this
they're they're binge watching things on
netflix and and they're all on youtube
none of these none of these platforms
are completely free but they're more
free than the sort of manipulation on
facebook i remember when we started free
the people we thought that young people
had short attention spans but it turns
out that facebook manipulates you into
not paying attention for very long so
what happened people that didn't like
that they migrated to youtube and and
other places um i think that i mean i i
believe in the wisdom of crowds um i
believe that people figured this stuff
out and i think
that the the revolution is going to be
those people choosing for themselves
i think the strange thing about the
internet is that it was so disruptive
and by
uh regulating the internet you can
really regulate basically every part of
human life i've never had a job that
didn't in some way involve the internet
which is sort of crazy there are
generations that that was not true for
even people who worked in congress who
wrote bills like they you know before
the rise of the internet there were
other ways of operating and now i can't
imagine life without it not just that i
mean even if you were at a fast food
restaurant these days you have apps to
order food so you're getting the
internet company and to schedule what
shift you're working i mean like
everything is done through the internet
so if you mean that like if you have to
comply by the internet aka the
government's rules then every part of
your life has to comply yep so we had uh
robert davia on the other night he was
telling us a really interesting story in
the after show
about uh i think he told us in the main
show like maybe it was after show how he
how he ended up getting into uh
no i think it was after show how he got
into acting and he said that you'd have
to call a number on a pay phone
that would have your messages stored for
you
so it's like he wakes in the morning he
runs down to a pay phone he puts the
coins in and then he dials the number
and he's like he gives his information
and then it reads him his messages and
he finds out he gets he gets the part
like that's crazy days
i remember when i was a kid you know i'm
36.
you go to your friend's house knock on
the door
he's not here do you know where he went
i don't guess i'm not going to see him
today that was life man internet before
internet banking i know you remember do
you guys were did you ever have them bro
before debit cards yeah before debit
cards you had a check you'd go to the to
drug mart and you'd you'd be like here's
a check for 17 it would take three days
to clear then you'd have to go to the
bank and you like talk to the cashier
write her a check and then she would
give you cash then internet banking
appeared and it's so convenient i can
send i can click a couple buttons and
you get the money
it's amazing how could i ever want to
turn back from that except that now they
have the power to click a button and
turn it all off yeah maybe they kind of
did before or say you can't send money
to certain people or you can't use this
service because we don't believe in your
ideology have you all watched catch me
if you can
yeah what was that what was that guy's
name the the con man
what was it you don't remember the name
the real name yeah
well no leo's the actor but he had his
characters his name i'm sure people in
the chat will give us his name but you
look at how easy it was
to con people back then like he made
fake checks like it actually wasn't that
difficult for him to do yeah he just
lied and they would do it reminds me of
that movie with ricky gervais the
invention of lying you've ever seen that
one yeah where he goes into the bank and
he's like he needs money and then all of
a sudden like nobody can lie in this
world and then also in his brain just
snaps and he goes i have 800 and she
goes it doesn't say that we must have
made a mistake here you go and then she
gives him the money that's what it felt
like watching catch me if you can oh the
character is frank abagnale yes frank
abagnale jr
yeah and he was like
he took uh in the movie what they show
is it's probably apocryphal it's
probably a movie but he bought little
toys with the pan am logo and then he
like soaked them and then peeled the
sticker off and put it on the check to
make it look official
man
these days
everything's
you know so much more secure but but i
will say i think it's funny that we're
all old people talking about you know
when i was a kid we had phones on the
wall
and uh but the reality is the real
purpose of this is
in in in walking away from land lines in
the more we move into this digital space
the less control we have
to the point where this is the craziest
thing
you don't even own your shows anymore
you don't own it's it's like you will
own nothing and you will be happy i hope
everybody listening realizes
that the the the agenda of the world
economic forum has been underway for a
very very long time
how many songs do you own
you don't you don't even own your phone
the software on it is lice is licensed
to you and at any moment apple or ant or
google can brick your phone they can
shut it off like that if they want to
i remember 10 years ago
apple filed a patent to create
geofencing that if your phone went into
a certain area that they deemed to be
fenced off your camera would not turn on
that's the world or you can buy a camera
and walk around with it they can't
control it a polaroid or something like
that
i saw a funny tweet where some guy said
you know the future is inconvenient i
was flying on a plane i'm flying on a
plane and my book ran out of batteries
it's like yeah that's that's the future
you know for convenience and we end up
losing control one of those jarring
things is when i used to have all these
cds i have like
500 400 cds or something i'd move around
from place to place every year and carry
this big giant tupperware tub of cds and
then all of a sudden it was digitized
and people didn't own their their music
anymore and i'm like i i still haven't
done it i won't do it i still have my
cds they're my parents house right now
um i have them all backed up on multiple
hard drives because that's music i
bought
music i own as far as i'm concerned
i was never told that i didn't own the
cd and everything on it when i bought it
so i own that here's the best part
there's this happened to a lot of people
they got banned from facebook
so what people get banned from facebook
right the only problem is they were
using facebook login now all of a sudden
they can't log into any of the other
apps they had synced with and some of
them are financial now that's crazy well
i've known people who you know use
facebook personally and upload pictures
of you know whatever their kids their
their life's going on and when facebook
blocks them and deletes their account
they lose all of that so
people i've known people to lose pic
videos of like their kids first step
because they put it on facebook so
grandma in a different state could see
it and it's gone and facebook won't give
it to you uh well my mom pop culture
crisis we talk about how important it is
to go to flea markets and tag sales and
collect vhs's because you won't be able
to edit out the content and then you'll
always have it unfortunately vss's are
not like super stable i think cds
probably hold up against weather and
heat and stuff like that a little bit
better but there is i think uh
an interesting crossroads where people
are gonna have to say like if it's
really important to me i should actually
get a physical copy that cannot be
virtually deleted trump should have
banned tick-tock
should have absolutely banned how i
agree kind of agree with you i don't
know if banning is the way yep how would
that have worked out if he had that i
think he was temporarily like restricted
wasn't it it was i think under some
conditions i mean there are a lot of
reports coming out right now and i don't
want to be too alarmist about it but of
in different states they're getting back
their uh like learning standards from
last year they evaluated kids and so
many kids are behind so yeah
and i think a lot of that is because
lockdowns were bad but also
we didn't intervene on the parts of the
internet that we should have and i don't
actually like intervention so it's hard
for me to say that but the tic-tac thing
is that
china is controlling what our kids are
seeing and they're banning shows like us
we got banned for no reason they just
knew just off the platform and it's
obvious they want kids to see
their
moral ideology so they'll grow up and
they'll not agree with this that's their
plan they want your kids
so conservatives have to win on the
education front and on that front and uh
trump banning it would have been a
seriously bad day for the cultists and
from what i've understood and read about
the algorithm for tick tock they
actually
changed the algorithm based on what what
country they're in so kids in china are
not served the same content that tick
tock users who are under the age of teen
in america are you know you might get
more engineering content served to you
if you're a teenager in china than you
would in america right that is in
america it's garbage in china they don't
allow it
so
so you know someone chatted that kids
aren't watching uh youtube they're
watching tiktok
actually there were several studies and
some polls done and found that youtube
is the most popular video platform for
for all ages but tick tock is very very
prominent among kids so if they're at
school they're probably on you know and
there's an ecosystem right so if you
have a creator who's popular on tick
tock they probably also have a youtube
channel and an instagram and you're
floating between sort of but they're not
going on youtube until they get home
they're on tick-tock when they're on
their phone but tick-tock is
creepy
chinese-controlled data being sent to
them there's a new style of
entertainment on tik-tok where it's like
they'll say a thing and then there's a
cut and then they'll say another thing
and then there's a cut and then they'll
say a third thing and then there's a cut
and it's like
those disjointed three second statements
edit it all together as if it's to be
one sentence as opposed to like just a
10 or 30 second converse statement oh
bro here's here's the best thing
so uh some youtubers figured out that
typos result in higher engagement
because when you have a typo in your
title people click it and then correct
you
so they started intentionally putting
typos in the headlines children then
started spelling the words wrong because
on youtube they were spelled wrong and
that's what they were exposed to
and that in that crazy
that's why anything to drive viewers and
to keep them there right like that's why
tick tocks uh like shows you video and
you immediately scroll in some ways
that's why youtube adopted shorts i
think because they want you to be able
to move quickly through a lot of content
let's let's talk about the apocalypse we
haven't talked about the story before we
have it here
would you take out a loan to buy this
week's groceries americans are
increasingly turning to buy now pay
later services for food and other
everyday essentials and there are signs
that the practice is putting some in
deep debt
so um
i just want to say
if you don't have emergency food
supplies
i think you're probably in a bad spot
and um you know not everybody can buy
them because you know we we normally
shout at safeandreadymeals.com
and it's like 2 or 300 bucks for a for a
month supply now it used to be like 100
something
inflation's through the roof
we ordered uh we ordered some food
we had some takeout got delivered and it
was like three people eating it was like
almost 100 bucks it's like a local diner
and we were just like what did we get
like how did
bite inflation people people really just
are frogs in a pot boiling as all this
stuff happens i just want to stress
when msnbc says we're in a civil war the
president comes out and says half the
country are extreme threats
and people are taking out loans to buy
food please pay attention to what's
going on because this is
extreme extreme and i'm going to say
this too
i've actually been looking at uh
properties in other countries already no
problem saying that notably i will say
el salvador sounds really awesome with
the bitcoin stuff they're doing so i've
been looking at el salvador for a while
but um
i want to stay in the united states and
make sure we can do what we can to
preserve our culture and preserve this
country
in the event that um
let's just say catastrophic defeat
defeats to the point of executions or
something then i'm like okay i'm going
to get away from this place but i also
want to point out
as i've mentioned before
there are points throughout history
where we've seen people flee countries
before it got to the point where there
are mass executions and there are many
countries where this has happened where
their people have been genocided in
various ways
so
seeing all of this
i'm not saying that anytime soon
anything like that's going to happen i'm
saying that
i'm going to buy a van and go live down
by the river and get ready to bug out
because it's getting insane
people taking out loans to buy groceries
you know you have to realize that means
something really bad is about to break
right i took out loans in 2003 to buy
groceries after college for a couple
years that was a rough rough point in my
life but i was making 12 bucks an hour
right after 9 11 tough to get a job 12
bucks an hour was yeah but for me but i
still had to take out a couple hundred
bucks a month for groceries and food
benefits exist but this is uh uh
americans are increasingly turning into
to taking out loans to buy groceries did
you guys see the chengdu riots i don't
know if you call them riots but the lock
down they're locking out oh yeah 20
million people and people are just
storming in and grabbing whatever they
can chaos there's videos of it people
are like grabbing groceries and pouring
giant amounts of rice this is a this is
a big
issue in china with with these lockdowns
and and when you run out of food in
china particularly if you're of a
certain age you remember mao's um great
experiment and socialism the great leap
forward when
when millions of people starve to death
so not having food in china is the
ultimate insult the ultimate moment when
you freak out and say i'm going to do
whatever it takes i might die in the
process of disobeying my government but
i have to have food because they
remember what it was like to slowly
starve to death
but but on the inflation thing like this
this is unfortunately um a very
predictable result
of spending six seven eight trillion i
can't keep track anymore how much money
we spent that we didn't have well not
just that the money supply was expanded
by what 16 trillion yeah it's all
financed
they basically printed the money and
they have very more exotic ways than
actually running a printing press but
this is all fake money and it's the
ultimate transfer
from
working people people that have money in
their wallets money in their savings
accounts people that have to buy
groceries
they
pay
while rich people but the the the
connected the political insiders and not
just politicians but but when you when
you print all this money there's
injection points in the economy and who
are those the banksters yeah um so that
you have this huge wealth transfer from
the poor to the rich
and this is part of bidenomics
and one of the reasons why he did that
speech
out of desperation is that people are
taking out loans to buy their groceries
can we just well i love pulling up the
m1 money stock here can i just show you
guys uh
something isn't right oh because uh bam
that's when the 12 trillion dollar
increase because savings were converted
to checking accounts basically but look
what that they did that to mask what was
coming right after that influx of
savings is that gigantic angle
was right here increase yes that went
from like i mean that's like a like what
a three three times it probably went
from like a 20 percent growth that's
like five times to like a 78 percent
gain it's like five yeah money supply
increased by 500 percent this is what uh
thomas massey called the cheese and the
trap
when they started giving out those those
relatively modest checks like every time
we passed another trillion dollar bill
just a small fraction of it actually
went to people
but we're now paying for that and all of
those people that got those checks are
getting utterly screwed by that spike
right there have you guys been paying
attention to like food costs and stuff
like that oh it's insane no it's been
getting crazier and crazier i remember
it was a year ago and i was like i went
to the grocery store and it was 600 and
i was shocked it's like oh now it's 800
pork is through the roof gotta get that
bacon man
it's getting more expensive but we have
our own chickens
so you know they they bop about do their
chicken business and then lay eggs and
we eat them so i don't got to worry
about the cost of eggs that's great i
think the problem with leaving the u.s
is that
as the people who fled cuba i think
during trump's tenure got up on on stage
were able to say there is nowhere else
to go and el salvador sounds great and
portugal sounds good to me i've been
looking at portugal it turns out a lot
of californians have been moving there
so there's no hope there
this is really the last place to go and
i don't know
but you know
the issue is that if the u.s if the if
the us does falter that's the reserve
currency it's going to be a wild ride
so you got to wonder what happens like
what actually you know matt what are
your thoughts what happens let's say
let's say the u.s just erupts biden
comes out tomorrow and he's like i think
it's time to to put an end to this manga
and he starts arresting every trump
supporter and the scot the sappo's
kicking doors and and then also the
economy collapses the us dollar is
kicked up out of the countries what
happens well like you're thinking about
uh escaping to latin america the most
stable economies in latin america are
are dollarized so they've they've linked
their currency bitcoin
in el salvador bitcoin um yes so i'm
going to go back to blockchain is that's
the only solution to all of our problems
because because i really think it is and
there's a reason why
um they're going after odyssey they're
going after bitcoin they're going after
blockchain
they hate this stuff because of the very
definition it's not controlled
the alternative to this economic
collapse is going to be
this technology that that makes us
independent of government
um it's easier said than done but what
happens if the dollar
is no longer the reserve currency let's
say tomorrow they're just like dollars
done
people that hold dollars are are screwed
so these central and south american
countries that are dollarized they're
all just belly up yeah well they they
they
eventually
will do what they did in venezuela where
the currency is completely worthless and
you know every every couple weeks they
pass a massive increase in the minimum
wage but it doesn't mean anything
because their their money's not worth
anything
um
hyperinflation is the logical result of
of this kind of stuff that the reason it
hasn't happened in the united states is
that we are tremendously wealthy and we
have we have things that no latin
american country has in terms of of
physical assets and wealth and and the
resilience of our infrastructure i'm
actually surprised that that we haven't
gotten that point already
and you realize that for all of the the
darkness and the things that the
government has tried to do to stop the
economy
there's a lot of entrepreneurship in our
country there's a lot of innovation
there's a lot of people that work their
butts off to make sure that there still
is food on the on the grocery store
shelves i thought it would be worse
but yeah yeah uh it's supposed to get
really bad in the next few months but it
was get really bad a year after a year a
year from now or so yeah
so they're saying the fall harvest is
going to be brutal but then next year is
where it really gets scary
yeah there's there's a there's a
cascading effect on all this stuff
because you you have you have the green
agenda you have energy shortages
you have
all
of the farmers and truckers and the
whole distribution chain think about the
millions of people between you and your
next meal that you don't know you don't
know anything about these guys
they have all been affected by what
we've done over the last two years
and and the question is did we break the
supply chain
or is it resilient and and i've been
impressed by the resiliency of it but um
one piece in that in infinitely complex
puzzle
shuts things down
and and maybe it's energy the most
obvious thing but it could be anything
and we don't even understand what it is
that sounded sad
i thought that was you were like the
optimistic i'm gonna white pill you guys
well i i was though because like i was
20 minutes ago you can go you can go
read the stuff that i was writing in
2020 about the supply chain and
predicting like um these stupid idiots
don't understand
how beautiful and complex this thing is
and if you decide that that guy can't go
to work but that guy has to go to work
well that guy that has to go to work is
dependent on the other guys that aren't
allowed to go to work
i expected this stuff to hit in 2020
2021
there's obviously a an impact now i
think
that people could easily fix these
problems if the government stopped
helping i don't i think the government
is helping their ideology i think the
the climate change zealots are like
it's time to push people down
i think look you only need to listen to
the words they say bill gates thinks
there's too many people what do you do
when there's too many deer in an area
you call the deer
so why should i assume
that when these powerful global elites
are coming out saying we're
overpopulated the planet's going to
going to implode in you know any in in
five ten years and there needs to be
less people you you it's it's at that at
that point it's more conspiratorial in
my opinion to assume they don't want
people to die
i'm not saying bill gates is going
around trying to kill people or anything
like that i'm saying they probably wish
it was happening at the very least yeah
well um if you're going to replace my
steak with bugs
they might succeed did you hear the
story about the thermostats where people
couldn't change the thermostats or the
locked out colorado and they were like
you opted into this program it's your
fault because what will happen is you're
gonna you're gonna you're gonna get uh
your your gas turned on or your heating
turned on and they're gonna say do you
wanna you wanna sign up for our energy
saver program it'll save you a hundred
bucks a year and they'll go what do i
gotta do nothing we just click check the
box and then you get 100 bucks off and
they go
cool sure they don't read it they have
no idea sure then it's 90 degrees
outside and they're like why can't i
change the temperature and they're like
you agreed to this dave that's what you
want very much like no i didn't no one
told me
so that's the future man you're gonna
live in a pod you're gonna eat the bugs
that's the gag you know i i was talking
about i did this bit on twitter where i
said
it's it's 99 degrees in your house so
you go to your thermostat but you find
you find you're locked out and it says
you know emergency energy emergency
governor's orders so you decide to go
take a drive and and open the windows
you go to your electric car and it says
minimal charge driving not available
governor's orders you think uh so you
figure i'm gonna go walk down to the
park and as you're walking down there's
a guy standing at a checkpoint and he
says sir you need your card if you're
gonna come through this checkpoint and
you're like but my phone's dead because
i couldn't charge my phone sir you don't
have a qr card you can't come through
and then you're like look man i just
want to go to the park and then he pulls
out a cattle prod
and that's where the electricity went i
feel like that's china today right it is
i know i'm not disgusted
yeah that's where we'll be soon just
like china and then so then after you
get tased you get up you walk back to
your house sit next to your pod home
reach in and grab a bag of crickets to
munch on and wait for the temperature to
drop what do you think is the resistant
like way around that
i don't know
farm chickens
yeah i don't i don't chickens eat
crickets
chickens you eat chickens you know what
i mean that's what i'm talking about
it's all about chickens that's true
everything goes back to chicks
you know ghosts are pretty cool goats
are good people they're good you know
cows are all right cows are chill and
you know and cows it's only a couple
years so you can eat the whole thing you
know what i mean so just kind of keep
making more of them eat grass there's a
lot of grass grass everywhere you know
in fact we got so much grass we got to
pay got to take it from us we have like
when you have big acreage
the farmers come and just take it all
for you they bail it all up and they're
like it's a couple hundred bucks for us
we need cats eat it and they take it and
you know how about we just get some
goats and then the goats eat the grass
and the goats give us more goats and we
eat the goats there you go why the
chickens yeah goats also give you milk
which you remember milking when i was
growing up i wanted to say they've been
pushing this energy plan in maryland for
a while now for over a year and i think
that people are going for it because
it's going to save them money and times
are so hard they're literally taking out
loans so they can get groceries it makes
sense to me you guys ever see that bit i
can't remember who did it where he's
like a get-rich-quick scheme and he's
like you put seeds in the dirt put some
water on it the food just grows right
out of the ground you can sell it you
sell to people to give you money for it
just comes right out of the ground it's
like people really don't like people in
cities really don't understand these
concepts i mean some people might be
thinking oh come on of course people
understand farming no dude kyle kolinsky
was on a plane and he took a picture out
the window at a bunch of farms said i
wonder why it looks like that and people
were like bro
dude
come on what is that circle is that an
alien thing yeah he's having like this
really insane like did you guys ever
notice this it's so weird i'm looking at
farms dude that's where food comes from
the article that we're looking at before
referenced um buy now pay later services
and i'm thinking of like after pay and i
think that comes into you know you can
pay
forty dollars for a shirt or you can
make four payments of ten dollars for
the shirt and i think some of that comes
into our we don't like to deal with the
consequences of our actions mentality
that a lot of culture have you know
there's instant gratification and
there's uh delayed repercussion with
that kind of strategy and i think it
makes people divorced from the reality
of the impact they're having on their
own personal finances obviously
inflation is a huge deal but i think
we're also trying to find ways to not
feel it and it's creating larger
problems down the line i think it's time
to move out to the middle of nowhere
you know before we moved out here west
virginia we were looking at montana but
montana is actually really expensive
like comparably expensive to being so
it's like you got to find the happy
medium where you're close to a city but
far enough away to where it's actually
cheaper but you have an airport looked
at wyoming i'd rather be up in a big
mountain somewhere with a satellite dish
but you just it's impossible to run a
business and fly guests in and things
like that plus there's no fuel and food
it's really it's a lot harder to come by
but uh surprisingly the property there
is comparably expensive you know so
we're all moving off the grid
i mean
nice aren't you on capitol hill i mean
the new the freedom stand we're setting
up is is going to be off the grid it's i
mean it's on the grid because we don't
we're not we're not trying to separate
ourselves from the grid for some
political point but we have the
capabilities of operating independently
with solar with weld water solar systems
and
you know electric cars electric bikes we
can charge them up with solar power and
massive batteries we're good to go yeah
you got to be independent and then uh
what we have over there we have like 18
roosters i think now
that's right
yeah chris doesn't want to eat him
though he's he he'd rather let him live
and just be free and i'm like but then
the fox eats them dude that's not fair i
want to eat them you know
but he doesn't want to eat them so your
chicago upbringing you guys aren't ready
i'm ready these chickens some of them
are dicks
you know like you know we got some some
chickens that are just mean and nasty
their food as far as i'm concerned the
ones that are really nice we'll let them
keep laying their eggs and have babies
and you know live a good healthy life
but you know you can't you can't wait
too long until you eat them
because then they get nasty and the
roosters are hard to eat anyway they're
rubbery but you just gotta put them in a
pressure cooker and cook them overnight
make rooster stew or something like that
do you have recipes
no no i don't you know could we make a
chicken cookbook though i feel like that
would be a tim cast product i think it's
funny that the chickens that we have in
chicken city are in like a truman show
and they have no idea that we eat them
and we're eating their eggs and they
just it's just oblivious and it makes me
wonder about our life and everything
that's going on in the world because
we're being treated they're treating us
like chickens
you know they're they're lying to us
they let our look i let the chickens do
their thing you know they they wake up
and they run around and they eat bugs
and and eat food and it's just there
it's a beautiful home they don't realize
that we are in control of their
existence and that's what i feel like
these these global elites and the world
economic forum types are doing to us
right now
just lying to us to control us and
they're like we don't care if they do a
podcast i don't care that you can scream
you know what i mean they don't care if
we do this you've all know harari calls
some people uh useless eaters he's
claimed there's like a class of people
that are considered useless the useless
class i don't think he would consider
you in the useless class because you're
actually contributing you know emotional
support for society and things but a lot
of people that just get home from their
nine to five drink bud light and watch
sports it's like the use he considers
them relatively useless which is i don't
know i don't personally they can do a
lot but you know if they're not doing a
lot
that potential is not connected wouldn't
the idea be that like someone who just
like consumes the products and does
their job actually they're very useful
because that's how you make your money
that's you're showing advertising too
no because a lot of these jobs are
useless and don't provide towards any
goal right
so the view that these people have is
you are useless your job is useless and
if you weren't around it'd be better for
everybody and that's that's scary
prospect people want to put on the
metaverse on on pharmaceutical
psychedelics that's i think you've all
know her he's with the world economic
forum he's thinks that that's the future
of the useless classes they'll be
put on like pharma or sterilize sykes
and in their verse experiencing what
they want to experience i'm sterilized
but they'll be happy about we're all
they'll be completely you look yeah it's
about keeping them docile
when nora link becomes public these
cultists are going to be lining up
screaming and begging for it
that's it
they're going to be you know but yeah
and we'll see though if we get to that
point where we actually do get you know
computer brain interface working because
there's some difficulties with it
technology may not be around the corner
elon musk is trying he's got monkeys
doing weird monkey stuff
would you sign up for it would you get
neuralink me no yeah but there is an
interesting point about right now the
issue with neuralink because it's like
what is it read only right yeah
right is where you get interest it gets
interesting
so i'll put it this way
if you could get a port attached to your
you know you know
brain stem or whatever
and it would probably be a magnet
wireless transmission i doubt it would
be like a plug that clicks in
but uh you you put it on the back your
neck and it writes to your brain and
then all of a sudden you're in lord of
the rings
you're in die hard you're john mcclane
everyone would want it
it would be that you'd be a literal
dream come true people would be like you
get to you mean i get to be the carrot
and then they go into a world where
their carrot they're just like running
around yelling like some people want
weird weird stuff man they'll be trying
to explain something to someone and the
person's like i don't get in there like
let me show you and then you see what
they're thinking and then it's going to
be like how do i compete i want to
interact with people like that i want to
show them what i'm feeling can i so i
got to get the plug this sounds
appealing to me
yeah it does doesn't it no it doesn't it
doesn't sound appealing to me this
sounds horrifying i feel like your brain
is your own personal space and to be
like well but if i give you a link you
can come join me here like no get out
but it's not even about that it's about
some guy goes to work at mcdonald's and
then he's just like he's making the
burger and he's like walking who's your
burger sir thank you very much here's
your drink and then he goes home and
he's like he takes a thing clicks it to
his his neck and then i'll say
i am valsanor hero of the fourth wind
and then he starts fighting dragons he's
gonna people are gonna beg for that
they're gonna line up and be like i hate
my life i wanna be a rabbit and then
they're going to go into rabbit sim and
they're going to run around as a rabbit
and they're going to go into goat
simulator and then run around
head button people and things like that
or goose simulator remember goose yeah
that goose game that game was fun
headbutt simulator would be cool
and it's gonna be time dilation so
they'll be able to go in for what they
perceive as 20 hours and then when
they're done it's only an hour's gone by
somehow would you not want that a bit
people dude people are gonna go visit
loved ones who died it's gonna get dark
and but people are gonna beg for it
they're going to be like in this
simulated world we've taken all of your
father's facebook posts compiled them
into an ai and now you can go and hang
out at a cafe for his birthday and
you're going to go in and he's going to
be there and he's being like you know
i'm a robot but i'm your dad and then
you're going to be like i miss you dad
and it could be to the point where
anyone that resists that could be seen
as a terrorist to the status quo like if
you wanted to stop people from getting
embedded in that system you're you're in
the way of what's right and what's good
and you are a danger to society like i
can see you're a religious zealot i mean
the thing is if you believe in liberty
you would let people sign up for it if
they want to be in it but ultimately
every time you come out of that
simulation you'll feel more depressed
you'll hate your life even more i think
you would hope that enough people want
to invest in the fact that they have a
real life that they can make whatever
they want out of it or they can go into
pain simulator and then when they come
out they're like well this isn't so bad
yeah but look at post-modernism people
don't believe in reality they don't
believe in objective reality they would
rather live you know what hey i say let
them do it in fact we should all agree
let's all the post-modernists how about
we give you guys neural link we hook you
guys up put you in the pods we'll make
sure that pod economy is working just
fine for all you because we don't want
you coming out and then we'll live our
lives everything will be fine and you
get to live the world you want to live
in everybody everything works we believe
in objective reality so we'll take
objective reality you take the pod
universe and we'll uh we'll we'll polish
those pods nice and clean all for you
and uh uh and there you go it works it
works for me
finally a happy ending to this yeah and
then it worked out this is such a dark
conversation yeah because if you do put
people in pods and then kind of let them
off on their own it'd be like letting an
ai figure out how to wipe out humanity
on its own if you don't watch it and and
watch what it's doing it can very well
be working to destroy you
i feel like i've seen this movie it's
it's interesting yeah i was just
thinking about terminator 2 last night i
don't really know
so but the issue with the matrix is it
shouldn't be robots to be people people
run the matrix and some people want to
be in the matrix and they choose to be
and what would really end up happening
or i think a probable scenario is that
if we actually built the metaverse you'd
have a lot of people and there'd be a
company and says we can hook you into
the metaverse permanently your body will
be suspended in a float solution we'll
take care of you to make sure there's no
injuries we'll keep you healthy and your
body will be regulated and the neural
link will actually stimulate muscle
growth and will provide you with a
feeding tube and in this universe you
will do work and that work will interact
with objective reality you can leave at
any time tons of people would sign up
for that and then what would you do in
the digital world coding
you know jobs related to the arts and
things like that and software
development
and just harvest your body heat get some
like no electric gel that's no you're
you're a software developer and or
you're a consultant or any kind of
non-physical labor job you'd host a
podcast and then people in the real
world listen to your show and you're and
you're just in a pod floating there but
your brain is creating this simulation
and you make money from that and then
you have to pay the pod company a
percentage of revenue or a month a
yearly fee of you know 20 grand or
whatever to maintain the pod for you and
you live in your own universe and then
in this universe let's say you host a
podcast and then the podcast is over you
stand up and you're like alright guys
thanks for coming everybody i'm gonna go
fight some dragons for the next few
hours and then fly away and then like
you know your guest is like i'm gonna go
be a dragon then turns into a dragon and
flies off that's the world people are
gonna want to live in and they're gonna
pay to do it and like your super chat
followers will be in your party at the
end of the night you're like now i'm
gonna fight dragons in like the top four
super chatters are gonna be in the party
with you fighting the dragons tonight
yeah you're gonna be back if you super
chat you're in the top four you get to
come fight dragons or aliens or zombies
or zombie alien dragons whatever
i totally believe you that people will
pay for this and people will want it it
just personally sounds so unappealing to
me i believe so fundamentally that you
have this life to live and you have to
do something with it in this time like
deciding that you are going to it's like
as if you were telling me i'm just
spending the rest of my life watching tv
like that's what i'm hearing when you
sign up for neurolink like you're just
looking to be distracted from the
reality of the world and if that's your
choice i respect it like i don't want to
tell people what to do but i think
ultimately you're lying to yourself if
you think you will ever be a more
satisfied person from
completely devoted post-modernists
they don't want to be what they are
they're like there are people who want
to be cats
there are people who want to be animals
and they they're people who want to be
cartoon animals they identify as these
things they would absolutely take the
neural link implant but it's better than
just watching tv like another it's like
if you were reading twitter all day and
then making an internet video show on
youtube at the end of the night like
kind of like exactly what tim does and
what i do see i mean the important thing
people need to understand right now is
that this show is actually produced in
the metaverse we're not real we were i
hate it here
hannah claire is actually a 30 year old
kidnapped send help
it's an interactive way to experience
humanity but you're saying that you
think power off like just being out in
the field is better like what do you
mean it's not good
i mean i think fundamentally
it's a deception right you're you may
feel like you're fighting dragons you
may feel like you have a podcast and you
might have some kind of relationship
with someone who else is pretending to
be something it to me reminds me of the
criticism you get of social media right
that everyone is putting out a fake
front and that's why we tell people to
stop checking instagram and twitter all
the time because it's actually bad for
your mental health you know it'd be
really funny though if like it turned
out all of this is one weird metaverse
simulation for hannah clare who's
actually a 56 year old morbidly obese
man who's like i just want to be a young
blunt woman
and so like you're sitting here being
like you're all crazy metaverse is
terrible but like it's actually your
simulation yeah i think if i were to
wake up and realize that i was in the
metaverse and that was true i would be
really miserable which means i would go
back into the matter right and i think
that's terrible like i think giving
people
you know we talked about earlier that
facebook intentionally tried to see if
they could make people depressed and
follow the content they produce
afterwards like that is what this is
opening the door to because what what is
the point of
not having you hooked up to the normal
link you're going to be on your deathbed
and your family's going to be around you
and they're going to be like we love you
nana and you're going to be like i lived
a good life and then all of a sudden
it's going to blink and you're going to
wake up as a 56 year old morbidly obese
guy you go
back to the salt mines and gotta go to
work but think of all the relationships
that you would perform in the metaverse
that you would think are real and then
if anything were to happen to your pod
they'd get deleted they're not real i
mean kind of but you know i don't lament
not hanging out with princess peach
after i beat mario so i had a friend
that did an ayahuasca ceremony and he
said it was like a two-day ceremony and
he said he lived another life in this
ceremony like a like a psychedelic
experience where he had family a wife
and children that he remembers and still
to this day
misses like he knows them that's why
yeah dude i've heard a lot of crazy
stories like that dmt is crazy
i think just being told constantly that
like ev like even if you forget right
you're in the you're in the metaverse so
intensely and you're doing whatever
if you ever were to be over you would be
destroyed right and i think that's why
you have to live your real life and not
your fake life and if there are things
that you are
aspiring to be right like i can't help
you if you want to be a cartoon cat
maybe you should draw one and become a
cartoonist or go to the metaverse you
could be a cartoon chao it's you know
don't go to the metaverse don't go
you're going in matt i'm not going in
yeah are you gonna i'm i'm analog i i
want to actually live the life i have so
call me old school will you work with
the developers i don't think it's old
school unless i can become a cat because
that's sort of something you can't yeah
in the metaverse you can be a kid i just
want to knock you that's how they get
you they get it's going to be like drugs
they're going to be like just try it
once see what the encounter is i just
want to knock stuff off the counter yeah
it's like all i've ever want to do is
climb up on someone's table and just
throw stuff on the floor scratch it you
could do that in your real life i just
want you to know now why did they do
that you know what i mean they're
dominant they do this thing where they
go to a door and then yell at you and
you open the door and they turn around
and walk away like they just want the
door open is that what it is
it's because cats are libertarians
you know what i love
i love it when they go up to a door and
they start yelling and then they'll like
put their paws under it and they're
shaking the door and yelling at you like
open it then you open it and they just
walk off yeah
they just don't want the door closed
yeah keep it open i had a cat who would
like stand there and scratch the door
constantly like he thought he could dig
his way through it you'd open the door
and he'd be like i don't even know why
you did that like i'm going the other
way now
so uh bocas downstairs in the pantry
he's always screaming like to open the
door and you do and he immediately runs
to these loose kibbles that are on the
ground because he's a weirdo and he's
he's tricking you he's it's a trick
because as soon as you walk away he
jumps into the box of bacon that's right
i see him do that and then he starts
tearing the bacon open and eating all
the bacon
and then so then when i caught him doing
it i picked him up and he just yelled
he's like
genius
yelled at me he was pissed yeah one time
it was really funny he was trying to go
in the garage and i kept blocking his
path and then he got really mad and just
went like this with his hand real slow
and then weft me one time on the leg
and then i was like what are you doing
and then he just walked away i went up
behind him he was looking out the window
and i kind of roughly petted him on his
sides and he turned around and swiped at
my face with full claw just got the hair
but he was letting me know i'm faster
than you sharper than you just don't
mess with me just a shot across about
yeah and i've never touched him that way
yeah you're only supposed to
go with the flow if they're further
right fridays are the best watch the
important news
if they start flipping their tails
everybody lay off everybody can relate
to you know yeah my cats are
hardcore objectivists oh yeah but rourke
ragnar and riordan
they absolutely believe that they are
superior of course and and frankly they
are
what's the hierarchy like over at the
kibby household um
they
they own everything and they eat better
than we do like when we're eating
crickets they're still gonna be eating
the good beef
um because that's the way it is but and
by the way like the the
the other half of this story and this
will upset some people listening dogs
are actually communists i don't know i
don't know if you could oh yeah
yeah dogs are coming always looking for
a handout always looking for like
secondhand affirmation like a pat on the
head
my cats don't do that stuff yeah cats
are libertarian do you think that a pet
dog if faced with a pack of dogs that
wanted him to join would look at you in
the eye and be like sorry bro i'm going
like
i'm a communist at heart 100 ooh yeah
don't trust them yeah don't trust me i
want to love dogs they look like
psychopaths when i look into their eyes
i think that's one of the reasons it's
so dogs are all right
it's so nice when a cat likes you
because like you don't have to whereas
dogs like they they think you're in this
together and cats are like i'm choosing
this relationship with you you are lucky
to have my dream cat gives you a little
bit of love but like it's a boost to
your self-esteem yeah
finally i matter yeah yeah dogs are
clingy but i like dogs dogs you know i
like dogs because they're loyal they're
like loyal soldiers you know they're
there for you and like you're not gonna
get your cats dude like you can never
train a cat to do anything they train
you can't even get bogus use a litter
box yeah piss it on the floor there's a
theory that the cats domesticated humans
back in the day oh that's how it all
happened it happened kind of
synergistically but a big part of it was
casual
cats are an invasive species that we
tolerated together one of the things
i've heard is like cats that's not true
that is incorrect they didn't meow they
started doing that to talk to humans
like that they they don't do this in the
wild and they do it for your benefit
which i think is hilarious dogs were
domesticated by humans and wolves slowly
being pushed together for mutual benefit
cats just hang out and people laugh
because they're funny and cats don't
bother us that's why they're they're
technically domesticated in that sense
but you don't you can train them but
they're not really tradable because
we did not like
livestock beasts of burden
all trained horses trained cats
sometimes people will train a cat
because you can but for the most part
they don't you can you can do some kind
of training with them but for the most
part because cats came into human
existence by like jumping through our
windows and then we laughed about it
not because they ate mice
uh terriers were bred for hunting mice
and rats
is there any way to get a cat a male cat
to stop peeing yes how diapers we have
diapers for him
there's nothing like that though you
must that must drive him he walks all
funny but if he's gonna piss on the
floor give him a diaper and they make
like those those sprays that are
supposed to like tell your cat not to
pee there and stuff like that yeah but
he's cat urine you like have to soak the
i don't know why i'm giving this advice
but anyways
i had a really great cat he died just
about a year ago and i was obsessed with
him but he went whenever i like moved or
something he had a really hard time
adjusting with p places and you have to
clean with apple cider vinegar because
it's so the smell is so intense they can
go back to exactly the same spot we're
gonna go to super chats if you haven't
already would you kindly smash that like
button subscribe to this channel share
the show with your friends head over to
timcast.com become a member we've got a
bunch of awesome shows up there check
out all the tim cast uncensored robert
davi last night talking about all these
crazy stories in hollywood it was really
really fun how he met pablo escobar
that's crazy because he was a bond
villain and i guess escobar
like saw himself in this bond villain
and was like why don't you come and you
know and it's a crazy story it's legit
you got a bag of emeralds or whatever
check that out let's read some super
chats
waffle sensei says facebook took down my
image of the email between facebook and
the white house they said it violated
their community standards under the
subsection of terrorism dark brandon
hath risen
yup david ruck says biden said trump and
extreme maga republicans are a clear and
present danger to democracy look up the
clear and present danger rule to see how
they'll start arresting their political
enemies
i think so i do
free men die free says now more than
ever it is important to amplify voices
like ron paul make it happen tim ron
paul and tim cass do it uh ron paul's
like top of the list we gotta we gotta
get a run on how do we get around dr uh
dr paul he's uh he's in dc tomorrow or
is he really really
does he have time
uh i'll i'll ask around yes
that'd be so cool he doesn't travel that
much anymore he's yeah um
but it's like you guys have talked about
being willing to go to him though right
yeah but also i think his people said
that he would come out here
um it's just scheduling i suppose but we
got to get robbed all day let's do it
yeah that'd be fantastic um we can do a
special
you know special interview with him
because he says you said tomorrow right
the memes would be fantastic oh it would
be so amazing you know i'm a big fan and
we also want to get rand on the show too
because rand's like
one of the only good politicians you
know what i mean
we we we're big fans of the paul's here
the paul family the pools the pauls
tim poole likes appalls paul's are good
people
like logan i like ron
like all the pauls
tim ferriss says joe wandered back
around to a dead mic i think your bingo
card won
can i take credit for that we have um
if walks wrong way that's true that's a
good point he did walk the wrong way he
turned around and went back and the mic
was dead yeah i win
what do you win
i won the i won the bingo i won the
bingo from yesterday you won the prize
yeah he started late he walked the wrong
way i got a free space he said soul of
the nation and he said trump
that was easy that was easy at the end
of the night he started to walk to the
left i thought but then he was just
saluting guys but he turned around then
stopped turned back around and that's
the wrong jill kissed him that was nice
but he looked like he was like oh
there's all these people watching
and then
i'm just surprised we made it through
the length of that speech to be honest
yeah it was actually more cogent he was
more cogent it was such a rough start
i'm like oh this is going to be rough
but he actually
he hammered his way through it like in
terms of his delivery skills it was
pretty reasonable all right grafty says
spin the ufo
okay
[Laughter]
get ready for this
where did this come from the ufo yes i
saw an ad on instagram and then i bought
it spinning and then we had desktop
cleaner one day and i made an instagram
video spinning it shh
and then it became a meme shout out to
adam kriegler for all the ufos out there
aaron bacon says twitter deleting
accounts which negative to biden
is that true that post negative content
i don't know
kevin brady says cnn didn't change it
for optics i super chat yesterday about
the tint balance being green and they
needed a magenta shift i'll tag ian on
twitter now in my post still bad optic
choice
on my you know maybe
but it's stupid and weird to do
it seems like a weird mistake for such a
huge network you know i don't know man
they also don't i don't believe them i
was like i don't give them the benefit
of the doubt the stuff right behind him
was like dark black at first and then it
slowly got they brought the light up on
that too
farrell says biden's speech is meant to
inspire violence following trump's
indictment my advice to gop voters do
not attend rallies or protests regarding
trump's indictment spread this message
focus only on voting and biden's
failures
i would say i 95 agree i don't know
about saying don't go to rallies and
stuff like that i get it though
they're gonna they're gonna january 6
people you're going to show up to a
rally and you're going to have a little
american flag and then some lunatic is
gonna do something and they're gonna
blame you for it
but what's the alternative tell people
not to engage in their first amendment
right to protest the key right now is do
not harp on 2020 that is not focus on
fixing the dominion proprietary voting
machines and making the code open when
in the midterms and you get everything
you want okay probably not depends on if
the republicans actually do anything but
i will say this your best chance right
now is to hyper focus on winning the
midterms
do not
i i think it's it's likely trump will be
indicted sometime soon before the
midterms and then we'll end up hearing
that some trump supporter got violent
either because a trump reporter got
violent or because it's a false flag
whichever reason you want to believe
that's why i'm saying people need to
stay away uh from any potential hot
situations or whatever
if you know people gotta have a right to
protest but if you're out and you see
stuff unfolding like january 6th you
better gtfo and i'll tell you why
i love protests you have a right to
protest but this is right now the
closing stretch of the midterms to get
some hearings to get some investigations
to get something done and there are
traps and minefields all around you
strategy is extremely important
when the midterms they're this is
desperation on biden's part they're
going to try and stop you
they want you to make a mistake they're
waiting for it they need you to make a
mistake
don't make those mistakes man
don't give them what they need
all
right all alpha zero beta says joe says
he's defending democracy but i don't
think the green party of north carolina
could agree less democrats love
democracy as long as it's two parties
not three
yeah what about the libertarian party
they don't like them either right no
they don't like us well the republicans
don't like us that much either it's yeah
it depends which way the the shift is
the shift i love i love the assumption
that the libertarians would take votes
only from republicans because that's
that wasn't true i don't think in 2016
right no i and i i think generally
libertarians have um a new community
that turns out to vote i never really
bought that libertarians steal votes
from either republicans or democrats and
it you know they might be divided
between republicans and democrats but
they're people that probably wouldn't
have showed up i briefly covered the
north carolina green party or some stuff
that's going on because they had a
really hard time getting on the ballot
this year and uh they said the
libertarian party was incredibly
supportive
yeah i
i like the idea of people having choices
how involved are you with libertarian
party um i i am a libertarian um big l
libertarian now and uh i
show up to their conventions
but i i wouldn't say
i'm i'm a big fan of the mises caucus
and uh i show up at uh state party
events and and speak for them but um
i'm waiting for for something to happen
i i think that libertarians spend way
too much time fighting with each other
and we got to get to this idea that not
everybody's going to be just as perfect
as i am and this is a libertarian
disease where like if a guy disagrees
with you on one thing
they go bananas
i want to build a big tent
libertarianism that is is like a fun
place to hang out
and we're not we're not there yet we're
not there yet we're we're fighting with
each other pissed off patriot says
hashtag pedo hitler
pedo hitler was trending like 200 000
tweets or something man that picture
yeah that's great that's burned in
infamy in my mind they're they're
screwed over that to be honest
that was they did not expect that i
really don't think so
and it is going to be used forever
forever and it's going to freak people
out they're going to look at that and
that's what matters feelings they're
going to see that image and it's it's a
creepy image of biden looking despotic
it's strange because it i've heard a lot
of descriptions like oh it was it was a
patriotic presentation you know be like
so this is patriotism done by people who
don't like patriots yeah hitler was
patriotic to germany this whole thing
was a one germany uh bring the german
fatherland together if you're german
first you know it's all about patriotism
doesn't mean it's good
yeah it's kind of funny like you could
you could cut and paste the speech and
part of it would have sounded like
something that ron paul would say or or
some sort of tea party
guy you know talking about liberty and
the constitution and all that stuff
and it was almost like a caricature of
someone that had no idea what those
words meant and we're going to pace them
all together
and then we're going to divide the
country seth hauser says the fbi can
easily stage a fake maga trump attack on
the capitol or whatever you think they
will not do it they've done it before
well we saw what happened with the
whitmer thing yeah it was like was it
like 12 fbi agents and like four guys
who were just like i don't know i guess
whatever ah you're under arrest
good job guys
derek jones says tim the right is
missing something the imagery was
deliberately chosen it was in part to
provoke the right to act irrationally
and violently just before an election
it's no secret voters don't like the
erratic and violent then maybe maybe
they knew they were gonna make biden
look like lunatic and it was on purpose
because they want maga people to be like
oh it's happening yeah and freak out
yeah i think it's a credible theory
i think everybody
needs to tell everyone else to stay calm
do not let anybody you know talk people
down if you if you're hearing people get
crazy
don't let them don't get crazy man you
got to police your own community and and
one reason to show up at rallies is to
make sure that that one guy and maybe
it's maybe it's a plant right you don't
know who this one violent guy is
but everybody needs to take
responsibility to shut that guy down i
remember i did a couple of videos
praising uh some leftist protesters
because an antifa guy started smashing
bricks with a hammer to pull out of the
ground or something and the left just
grabbed them and brought them to the
cops yeah and i'm like yes that's what
you have to do yeah because the peaceful
protests are a good thing and we're
helping
and they help your cause this guy got
violent they stopped him and then the
optics were good it's like yeah hey look
we but you know the problem is a lot of
these lefties they support antifa when
they go and destroy the working-class
neighborhoods and stuff and so
you know i get it you reap what you sow
you're going to lose support because of
it
it does seem like biden speech was a
provocation to action for people and
they just have to ignore it i mean tim's
totally right you have to focus on
midterms
but by the way just a big mistake
the idea that that you're going to
divide the country and and the imagery
um with everything else sucking that bad
even if they get all their guys to show
up they're turning out independents that
otherwise were sort of riding the fence
right now
i think it was a colossal strategic
mistake unless they get the violence
that they want
cheddar 2648 says maga is a third-party
coalition of gop conservatives
independents and patriotic democrats
trump is perot's successor a businessman
outsider who infiltrated the gop and
beat them at their own game
yeah i don't know prospero is wild yeah
yeah
noah zork says vote quartering for the
griftees phone and pc oh what does that
mean i don't know what the gravities are
the grifte is an award ceremony
is this because we're bordering and
selling coffee yeah he's uh he's a
self-acknowledged greatest grifter on
earth i don't know jeremy are you are
you i think he was into it oh really
he's got a new place it looks cool yeah
really new house yeah
coffee money dude yeah big coffee he's a
he had big coffee quartering is a coffee
baron
yeah he is got to be careful coffee
baron
it's funny because he super chatted us
like a ton of money to shout out his
coffee
i just find it hilarious
he did that during a chair cast right
yeah
that was fun
oh he's number three griftees.com
number one tim's number six uh well i'm
going down nick rikita yeah you're down
from uh wherever you take it away i'm on
there too you're on there
is number two my name's under your name
i don't know oh yeah okay really yeah
you're selling you're number seven
no no my name is like a sub sub name
under your name it's in number six i
don't know okay that's unfair to you ian
yeah you you you griff that graphene
like nobody else next year big graphene
big on the refuse
so uh i think that was the court the
quartering was always above me i don't
know good for him man good bravo sir
bravo sir so what's the website
grifties.com
grifty's i don't have the griftee's been
around i'm just curious i haven't the
second annual second annual nice how
many how many are there hoteps been told
you presents the grifties how many how
many gritties are issues what are they
yeah what are they actually like five
three don't no they're requirements i'm
curious are there categories like
like best female actors ghost of kiev
that's another one nominated i i don't
know i don't know enough about it yeah
yeah but there's a video hotep nation
presents 20 21 griftes awards 2020 oh so
2022 this is from last year yeah all
right we we should uh we should we
should cook
hey
let's we'll sponsor a big event no joke
let's do it oh yeah like let's put a
budget behind this and actually get some
awards made and it would be amazing and
if jeremy won and we had him he came out
with a speech and like the coffee and
then like brought to you by hilarious
dude that would that would that would be
amazing actually we should we should do
it i'm gonna do it hotep
let's do it we love it
it's the only award show we can get
behind yeah i know that sounds pretty
fun actually it'd be cool joe novak says
loved the mtg playing mtg skit if she's
looking for a real challenge my wife has
some killer decks no offense to ian i
loved the part when in the in the full
episode marjorie chats in the forum blue
sucks and you suck
oh no she says white sucks and you suck
yeah
that's great that forum seems amazing
yeah that was good what about marger
taylor green versus post malone in magix
that's the what we need that's the event
we didn't know we needed grail
that would be great do you play magic
the gathering no i don't either andy
welsh says the darth jar jar theory
postulates that due to the extreme
audience backlash lucas was compelled to
rework the entire prequel trilogy and
abandon his original plan to reveal jar
jar as the true phantom menace
it's true well yeah jar jar was the bad
guy the whole time i knew i've heard
that theory yeah
yeah i guess the ending of the sequels
is that
um the emperor is now a young woman is
that what that's what happened
he says something like strike me strike
me down and i will take your body or
something like that right yeah well i
didn't see the movie
he said something like that he's like i
found a way to live forever if you
strike me down in anger i'll transfer my
energy or whatever
and then she does
and so i was like so is she like the
emperor is her no like he took her body
over that's weird the emperor was like
this whole
nine movie aqua so that i could be a
young woman see he's the guy who needs
the metaverse yeah
i don't know somebody told me i was
wrong about that before or something
like that
r bryce well 21 says if you haven't
already look uh if you haven't already
look into executive order
14067 and think about how the inflation
is manufactured and remember the social
credit score they were talking about
with the vax pass it's a bit scary and
would love to hear your take on it tim
what is that what is that 1406 ensuring
responsible development
of digital assets is what it's called
uh signed on march 9 2022 83rd executive
order signed by president joe 83
executive orders signed by the guy tell
us of the order is to develop digital
assets in a responsible manner it's a
why an executive order though it's not
an emergency
he is he likes a good executive order i
feel like i haven't looked at the
numbers but we should let this should be
congress's job
they're the money people
what do we got
ugly swan says not my line but it's good
our task is to look at the structure of
why we are failing as human beings and i
say all of us and if you don't have
faith in the people what do you have
faith in
chickens chickens
chickens will save us chickens and bacon
yeah we have a frizzle chicken you know
those are the feathers are curled and
it's laying blue eggs it's a white
chicken with frizzled feathers laying
blue eggs how about that you'd miss that
if you were in the metaverse that's
right and then what happens is if you uh
frizzle babies
you have to breed them with non-frizzled
chickens
because if you breed two frizzles you
get a frazzle and their feathers
disintegrate and then they're just naked
chickens so what happens is you do a
frizzle and a i guess a normal farm
chicken and then half of them will be
frizzled when they get older what do you
think about faith in humanity
what do you mean do you have it
but what does that mean faith you mean
like the the success of the
sustainability of the species
in the faith in humanity future about
math it's the probabilistic outcomes of
what happens to humanity even if we blow
ourselves up some humans will still
survive and then give it a certain
amount of time and then humans come back
that's the vibe i'm getting because the
technology's so good i can't imagine
that we didn't already succeed in some
way that we've been able to get to this
point
shell beach says chickens are tim's
graphene yes that's true but i think ian
talks about graphene more than talk
about chickens but i do talk about
chickens a lot and you know a lot of
times i talk about grasses because you
make me do it
push me
graphene is a hexagon i'm just kidding
by the way we got we got some jersey
giants i want to get a picture of
graphene behind me on the wall i'm gonna
do that later picture of griffin we got
uh jersey giants they're the biggest
chicken breed and there's four babies
in the uh incubator right now yeah
they're scared have you noticed that
they're they're little they're they're
store-bought so i want a frizzle
jersey giant crossover so we have a
really huge chicken with like the curly
wing and then what we do is once we get
that we breed it with the silkies and
they're called uh sizzles sizzles yeah
they have curly very soft fluffy
feathers yeah and they're massive
yeah super big
and then we're gonna start
having the biggest breed with each other
and eventually we'll have like five foot
tall chickens we can ride yeah that'd be
great
that's the plan man
no you'll never really be able to i'm
pretty sure but there's uh the biggest
rooster is a brahma he was three and
three and a half feet tall or something
like that
crazy video
massive thing i don't even know how
thing would reproduce it would crush
whatever it stood on
yeah yikes yeah i don't know
i'm stuck thinking about five foot
chickens yeah yeah
stuck on that yeah i feel like this is
our next project yeah
in our dystopian future when there is no
energy we will be riding chickens to el
salvador yeah that'll be fun
or in el salvador
because they've adopted bitcoin as their
national currency when the system
collapses they'll be the wealthiest
nation on the planet
it'll be like you know the new the new
shining city on the hill or whatever
all right
random user says lydia let him know that
max keiser is looking to start an
english english international news
station in el salvador with government
help up his alley interesting
well we know max max is awesome we're
good friends with max tell tim yourself
man i've known max for for a long time
we've said we've hung out some really
fun fun times in france and we've had
them on the show i think uh just was it
just one time or what twice twice yeah
we got to have them back so max and
stacy are amazing yeah big fans
david c kronk senior says if ian can see
ghosts he can be a happy medium oh i've
seen infrared light
one time i woke up out of a deep sleep
and i saw it going in it looked like it
was going into my phone but that's just
because my perception was warped and i
lost lost perception of it but yeah you
can visualize you can you can perceive
infrared light which may be ghostic
anthony says we eat our roosters we use
them as roasters same taste as hens i
guess if you eat them young enough
you know their food they're better
everyone just hold out for the tim cast
official chicken cookbook that's right
to be good i don't know chicken pot pie
how to cook how to serve chicken it's
really it's really nuts when you go
order wings at like a restaurant and
it's like you order six wings that's
three chickens
well i guess technically if you get
flats and drums then it's like one and a
half chickens
but still crazy
you're like i will have one and a half
chickens worth of wings and flats you
make uh coco van with uh roosters yeah
oh what's that big old chicken it's uh
basically um chicken cooked in wine it's
a classic french country dish oh really
yeah in our cookbook we can have matt
kibby's coco van
i make a pretty wicked coco van
neglectful sausage says people in the
matrix didn't get shoved into pods by
the machines man did it to themselves
the ultimate social safety dream is
metaverse no one can be harmed it'll be
illegal to not go just like reckless
driving imperial reckless driving
imperils you
adrian curry says four days brine
and all day in the crock pot makes any
rooster taste perfect oh brine that
sounds amazing another we've got a fee
for our cookbook we gotta figure out
which rooster we're gonna we're gonna
execute
you know we should have a trial there's
somebody to choose from yeah we should
have we should have a truck trial get
them lawyers it'll be great
chicken lawyers i'll i'll bring the wine
it'll be delicious sounds great yeah
brine four days in front and wine that
sounds really good try both of them then
we just have a cooking channel where we
only make chicken
crock pot
starling ex night says tim big fan i
work in the intel community for a living
with focus on international incursion
and influence social media is being
incredibly arrogant and y'all are right
pushing maoist like info ops this is
what our adversaries need to break us
yeah i think it's probably china you
know that's what trump wanted to ban
tiktok because
it's china it's definitely china
and they got your kids man
what does it say adrian curry says trial
on stream should we should we cook the
rooster and then have it here on irl and
we're eating
the roots
yeah during the show
special cooking show she's suggesting we
we figure out who's guilty live oh i see
i say trial bring them all into a room
ask them some questions who done it yeah
which which you know one of them is
guilty so we were talking about this
because uh
we have one
barred rock
rooster like a zebra stripe looking one
like white and black named dorothy
all the boys want her i don't know why
because i don't understand chicken you
know what i mean i just look at chickens
the same to me she's extremely beautiful
dorothy and vanessa she's hot are both
well i'm assuming that's what it is
right dorothy and vanessa both
are barred plymouth vanessa's got like
an angry brow she walks around and all
her sons do too that's crazy yeah so
when you when you look at we have a
bunch of black star boys that's when you
breed the rhode island red with the
plymouth um the bard rock
so the boys you can tell which one's
dorothy's and which one's vanessa's
because the angry eyes but dorothy's got
like big round eyes
she was she we had her lock her up
because she was getting hurt and then
one day she accidentally got out and
immediately the boys ran over and just
like were like they wanted they wanted
her man
you know
it's just
she's got those
pheromones yeah i don't know man maybe
maybe the roosters were like yo look at
her butt feathers
maybe we should have a chicken beauty
pageant and then she can hand down the
crown and then they'll all know who to
be attracted to next yeah we had to
separate her from the boys because they
they were injuring protective uh custody
crazy yeah wild she's got a lot of kids
though yep no kidding yeah they're huge
too vanessa's sons are
nasty
they're massive and they're really angry
and mean that's why i'm like i want to
eat them you know they're food now
arrogant little
pricks
all right let's grab a couple more super
chats
mth says they're going to memory haul
that biden photo from last night people
are sharing it everywhere but it's
surprisingly hard to find through google
it is actually hard to find through
google you search for a bunch of terms
and they give you similar ones but
they're different download and save it
now then put it on your family christmas
card we got all on instagram yes they
banned it joe rogan's got it on
instagram this is my point like google's
banning it but it's everywhere yeah
right they're trying to stop it but they
can't
matthew says tim look at the ncla
discovery pretty sad what is that
no idea
the masternator says does tim root
against peter griffin when he fights the
giant chicken no i think they're both
they're both uh responsible
murph murph's kick says tim let me make
roberto junior some jordans seriously
check my ig brother okay
you're gonna make jordans for our
rooster that sounds amazing
okay
awesome sounds good
my friends if you haven't already would
you kindly smash that like button
subscribe to this channel share the show
with your friends become a member at
timcast.com to support our work and you
gotta check out the cast castle show new
episodes tuesday at seven we had
marjorie taylor green
playing magic the gathering and it's a
really funny episode and then uh we uh
we've got um a four-part series coming
out starting next week this is going to
be this is going to be what is it what
does that make it out to like an hour
long total
no it's going to be like an hour and 20
minutes the whole arc when it's done and
there's going to be multiple cameos in
it and it's going to be it's it's really
funny and uh spicy i'll just put it that
way so check it out also don't forget
check out tales from the inverted world
episode 10 just came out if you're into
uh true crime mysteries and stuff like
that check that out you can follow the
show at tim cast irl you can follow me
at tim cast matt you want to shout
anything out yeah just follow free the
people at freethepeople.org or check out
me and check out my show kibion liberty
on blaze tv
i'm hannah claire brimlow i'm a writer
for timcast.com you should go there
every day click on the read tab and see
what me and my other uh journalist
colleagues are up to you can find me on
instagram at hannah claire.b and if you
have any suggestions for what i should
say in my intro i guess to make it
longer
let me know
you guys follow me anywhere on ian
crossland on social media and check out
the cass castle if you want to see what
happened i was actually in that movie
with marjorie taylor green it was it was
spectacular and i'm looking forward to
doing more perhaps with marjorie again
in the future perhaps with other great
actors that come on
and and show their stuff great to be
there great to see you see you next week
thank you guys all very much for tuning
in on this friday evening hopefully you
were all chilling hard while we were
talking you guys can follow me on
twitter and mines.com at sourpatchlids
as well as sourpatch let's stop me i
wanna i think i'll shout this out i
think it's fine to shout out we have two
guest cameos i think just two maybe
three actually in the next episode
we might have three
yeah
robert robert davi
spectacular it's an amazing cameo it's
going to be brilliant so check it out
tuesday at 7 p.m thanks for hanging out
we'll see you all next time
you